PLEASED TO CALL TO ORDER- THIS
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
TWENTY ON THE TWENTY TWENTY
UNITED STATES CENSUS AND
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE CENSUS AND I WANT TO THANK
MY COACH HERE CENTER I'M BURKE
AND ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE- MARC
BERMAN- FOR- JOINING ME TODAY
IS WE- ARE JOINTLY CHEERING
THIS IS A- WHAT WE CALL THE
LAST CALL. THE FINAL COUNTDOWN
INSTANCES TWENTY TWENTY- IT'S
OVER EXCITED ABOUT- WHAT'S A-
ON THE WAY. WE ARE ONLY THIRTY
DAYS AWAY FROM MARCH TWELFTH.
WHICH IS THE DAY WHERE
HOUSEHOLDS WILL BE BEGIN
RECEIVING THEIR INVITATIONS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS. AND I AM PLEASED
TO WELCOME BACKTHE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE TOWN OFFICE AND
VIRTUALLY PUBLIC AFFAIRS I TO
SHARE WITH US CALIFORNIA'S OUT
READ STRATEGIES AND EFFORTS IN
ASSURING AN ACCURATE COUNT. AS
WE LAUNCHED AND THE- NEXT
THIRTY DAYS WELL ACTUALLY I'VE
ON APRIL FIRST BUT WE PEOPLE BE
GETTING STUFF. THE CENSUS WHICH
IS MANDATED BY THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION HAS BEEN
CONDUCTED EVERY TEN YEARS SINCE
SEVENTEEN NINETY. AND SIX TO
PROVIDE AN ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE COUNT OF THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. CENSUS DATA AS USE
NATIONALLY TO PORTION SEATS FOR
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
AND TO DISTRIBUTE BILLIONS. OF
FEDERAL FUNDING. AND WHILE THE
CENSUS IS CONDUCTED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS LAUNCHED
MULTIPLE EFFORTS TO ENSURE AN
ACCURATE AND COMPLETE COUNT. IN
OUR OWN STATE. ON APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE FOR
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS TO ADVISE
AND ASSIST THE STATE CENSUS
OFFICES OUT REACH OPERATION.
AND THIS COMMITTEE IS NOW
CHAIRED BY SECULAR STATE ALEX
PADILLA AND I WANT TO THANK HIM
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. WHO'S BEEN
ACTIVELY COLLECTING INPUT FROM
THE COMMUNITY LEADERS ACROSS
THE STATE PROVIDING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON REACHING THE
HARD TO COUNT. IN ADDITION THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
INVESTED A RECORD ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS COUNT. MORE
THAN SIX TIMES WHAT THE STATE
SPENT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TEN COMBINED. AND AS A
RESULT THE STATE CENSUS OFFICE
HAS BEEN ABLE TO USE THESE
FUNDS TO INCREASE STATEWIDE
PARTICIPATION THROUGHOUT
REACHING COMMUNICATION. FILLING
GAPS AND CENSUS BUREAU OUT
REACH AND I THINK WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT- THE FULLNESS OF
OUT REACH ALTHOUGH I KNOW THE
CENSUS BUREAU STAFF IS WORKING
VERY HARD. AND FORMER FOR AN
FORMING STRATEGIC LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS TO BE SURE WE
REACH TO. EVERYONE WE CAN REACH
AND CALIFORNIA FOR COMPLETE
COUNT. SO THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE PUBLIC TO LEARN. ABOUT
HOW THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
COUNT OPERATION WILL UNFOLD IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS
LITERALLY. SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT THESE
PLANS TO LEARN HOW WE CAN. MOST
PROBABLY PARTNER AND TO BE SURE
THAT WHEN APRIL FIRST. COMES
STARTS OF THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS THAT WE COUNT EVERY.
PERSON RESIDES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT I'D NOW
LIKE TO TURN TO MY CO CHAIR
CENTER TIMER BURKE FOR HIS
REMARKS AND TO SOME MEMBER AND
CHAIR BERMAN FOR HIS. THANK YOU
CAN. I WELCOME EVERYONE- I
EXPECT TO HEAR LITTLE THEME
MUSIC YOUR LAST CALL FINAL
COUNT ON IT BECAUSE THE SONG
WOULD GO WITH THAT. AND GOTTEN
TOOK HIS CUE- SO I WANNA I
WANNA THANK- ALSO CHAIR BERMAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO FOR BEING
HERE THIS IS. IF NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT CERTAINLY ONE THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS YEAR AS
A STATE INITIATIVE- WERE VERY
CLOSE LONG PROCESS ONE OF THANK
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN ENGAGED-
WE'RE ABOUT TO SEE I THINK
MAILERS HITTING DOORS AND
PEOPLE KNOCKING ON DOORS. OF WE
WANT TO WELCOME CENTER TITLE
ALSO AND SENATE THERE ALSO.
USUALLY WE CENTER PAN WAS QUITE
ELOQUENT YOU MISSED IT HE
BROUGHT CLOSE TO TEARS YOUR
GLOBAL TO GO. RIGHT SO WE WELL
WILL THE RIGHT THEY'LL BE
REPLACED- I WANT TO THANK IN
PARTICULAR- THE CHIEF OF
STAFF'S ON YOUR LONG BEEN
WHOSE- HIT THE GROUND RUNNING I
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS WITH I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS WHAT.
OUTREACH EFFORTS HAVE. BEEN
EXECUTED IN TERMS OF ENGAGING
LEGISLATORS THEIR DISTRICT
OFFICES ALL OF US WE ALL HAVE-
CONNECTIONS TO OUR COMMUNITY
THAT'S HOW WE GOT HERE. AND
WERE ANXIOUS TO HEAR HOW YOU'RE
USING THOSE CONNECTIONS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
PARTICULARLY THE HARD TO COUNT
AREAS I KNOW OF A NUMBER OF
HARD COUNTY OR IS IN IN MY
DISTRICT. ARE THE DISTRICT
OFFICE ARE BEING ENGAGED IN
MAKING SURE WE GET TO THOSE
HARD TO COUNT. AREAS OF THOSE
HARD TO COUNT. INDIVIDUALS ARE
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT-
LET ME NOW TURN IT OVER TO- TO
YOUR BERMAN FOR HIS REMARKS.
WELL THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG-
I THINK THIS WILL BE THE LAST
TIME WE ALL GET TOGETHER.
BEFORE THOSE FIRST SETS VOTERS
COME OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF
MARCH- THE NEXT THE NEXT TIME
THAT WE GET TOGETHER- AS A
JOINT SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING.
WILL PROBABLY BE TO EVALUATE
WHAT WORKED AND WHAT DIDN'T-
WITH. EITHER THE INITIAL PHASES
OF THE STATE'S PLAN AND EFFORTS
OR MAYBE ACTUALLY WHEN THE
WHOLE CENSUS EFFORT. IS
COMPLETED. TO DO A LITTLE BIT
OF AN UTOPSY- TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THINGS WENT- AND IT ALSO
SEE MIGHT BE TOO STRONG A WORD.
MY HOPE IS THAT WHEN WE ALL GET
TOGETHER AGAIN AND THE TIME
SPENT ON WHAT WENT WRONG IS
VERY SHORT- AND THE TIME SPENT
ON WHAT WENT RIGHT- TAKES UP
299% OF THAT MEETING. BUT TO
ENSURE THAT I THINK THERE ARE
YOU KNOW IT'S SOME THINGS THAT
WERE HOPING HERE TODAY AND SOME
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE- BASED
ON FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
FROM FOLKS AT THE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL LEVEL. I JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE REALLY- EXECUTE.
OUR STRATEGYIN THIS LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS- LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS- BEFORE. ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FORTY MILLION-
FOLKS GET LETTERS IN THE MAIL
IN AND GET ASKED TO COMPLETE
THE SENSES. I DO WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
EVERYBODY- THAT'S WORKED SO
HARD. OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS-
ON THE CENSUS CENSUS EFFORT.
WHETHER IT'S OUR OUR CBO
COMMUNITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL-
THE REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS-
THEY CBO IS THAT IT- ARE-
PLAYING SUCH AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN TERMS OF BEING THE
INTERMEDIARY BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE LOCAL CBO IS ON THE
GROUND- I WANT TO GIVE A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO THE
PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY- WHO I
KNOW IS STEPPED UP HUGE- IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS- YOU NOW
THEY MADE ME A PROMISE- WOULD
TWO YEARS AGO WHEN THE
PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY
REQUESTED THAT THE STATE PUT UP
I THINK IT WAS AT THAT TIME.
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS. SAID
WILL MATCH ONE FOR ONE- AND
OTHER STATES BUT OF A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION. SO I
ASSUME THAT THAT EVERYONE'S
RIGHT OPENING THOSE CHECKBOOKS-
BUT NO I'M SURE THAT THAT THE
YOU KNOW THE- THE CONTRIBUTIONS
WON'T GET. THAT HIGH THEY DON'T
NEED TO BECAUSE THE STATE HAS.
PUT SO MUCH MONEY TOWARDS IT BY
NO THE PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY
JUST AS- DOING A LOT OF TO FILL
IN THE GAPS WHERE THE STATE
ISN'T. NECESSARILY PROVIDING
RESOURCES TO THE FOLKS ON THE
GROUND- SO REALLY LOOKING FOR
TO TODAY'S CONVERSATION YEAH
THIS IS THIS IS DEFINITELY A
TIME FOR. OPEN AND HONEST
COMMUNICATIONS ON ON WHAT STILL
REQUIRED. TO FINALIZE PLANS AND
EFFECTIVELY ALLOCATE RESOURCES
AND I'M SURE THAT THIS HEARING.
WILL FACILITATE THAT EFFORT AND
I'M I'M ALSO JUST REALLY-
EMBOLDENED BY THE TURN OUT THAT
WE HAVE FOR THE HEARING THIS TO
YOU WE DON'T GO TO A LOT OF.
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING WHEN
WE'RE NOT SHARING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S SO THE FACT THAT
SO MANY OTHER SANDERS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THEY'RE HERE. YOU KNOW A
REAL IN CASE IN A- HOW
IMPORTANT THE- IS TO ALL.
DISTRICTS DOLLAR ARKANSAS AND
LOOKING FOR. TO MAKING WE GET
THIS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
CHAIR BERMAN I JUST WANNA ALSO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THE FACT THAT
WE'VE WORKED AS A BICAMERAL
EFFORTS- IN THE LEGISLATURE TO.
OF BOTH- OBTAIN FUNDING AND
ALSO- IN TERMS OF OUR OVERSIGHT
AND OUR PARTNERSHIPS. AND THIS
IS- YOU KNOW SOMETIMES A TWO
HOUSES HAVE LITTLE RIVALRIES
BUT I THINK IN THIS EFFORT WE
ARE TOTALLY. ON BOARD WITH EACH
OTHER. YES AND I THINK YOU KNOW
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
TO MAKING FOR MAKING THAT
HAPPEN- I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
INVITE THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
RESPECT SELECT ME AS IF ANYONE
WISHES TO MAKE ANY FURTHER OF.
ANY OPENING REMARKS AT THIS
TIME. OKAY SOME CHOW YEAH I
JUST WANT TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
THANK ALL THE THREE CULTURES-
AND THEIR TEAMS FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND LEADERSHIP ON THIS
TOPIC- WE STARTED- THIS PROJECT
AWHILE AGO THERE'S A LOT OF
BEHIND THE SCENE WORKS I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU.
AS WELL AS YOUR- TEAMS ALSO
LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
PRESENTERS FOR BEING HERE TODAY
TO. A SHARED THE UPDATE- WITH
US AND ARE YOU KNOW I'M KIND
EXCITED BECAUSE IT'S COMING SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I SERVED
RAZA. YEAH I IN THE THANK YOU
ALSO FROM FOR YOUR WORK AND-
SINCE CENTER AND NUMBER AGAIN I
WORKED ON TOGETHER. ON THE
BUDGETING- AND WE- PUSH REALLY
HARD TO GET MORE. FUNDING I'M
REALLY HAPPY FOR THAT AND I'M
GLAD THERE'S- THE CONTINUITY
FROM OUR EFFORT ON THE BIKE
BUDGET NOW. WITH THE ACTUAL- ON
RELEASING. OF THE FUNDS AND IN
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES A WEEK.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF AREAS
THAT I'LL BE ASKING ABOUT ON IN
PARTICULAR- BECAUSE WE- MADE A
POINT TO SAY. FOR EXAMPLE IN
OUR- IN OUR SCHOOLS. ALL WE
WANTED SPECIFIC AMOUNTS OF
MONEY TO GO TO OUR SCHOOLS. ON
AND IN THE- LANGUAGE. OF
COMMUNITIES THAT HAD. DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES AS BEING TE- VERY
VERY HARD TO COUNSEL. I'M
ANXIOUS. TO HEAR THE REPORT-
AND ARE I WANT TO SEE THE
PROGRESS THAT'S BEING MADE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SUMMER
RAMOS. THANK YOU I'M A- CO
CHAIRS AND CERTAINLY OUT SORT
OF THANK YOU FOR THE HARD WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE FROM THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON DOLE CHAIRS
AND CERTAINLY COMING TOGETHER
ON THAT. LOOKING FORWARD TO-
HEARING FROM THE DIFFERENT
PRESENTATIONS OF THE PANELS
THAT ARE YEAR. AND IN
PARTICULAR THE HARD TO COUNT
AREAS AND HOW WE'RE DEALING
WITH THAT AND THE PRESENTATION
SPECIFICALLY- WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AND HOW
WE'RE MAKING SOME LEAD WAY.
INTO THOSE AREAS THAT ARE THERE
SO I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
THE TADA. JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AT THE CO CHAIRS- FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP. IN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO THE
COMMUNITY- FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK- SO FAR AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM MARK
TODAY ABOUT THE PROGRESS MADE.
OKAY THANK YOU AND I JUST THE-
BEFORE WE BRING UP OUR FIRST
PANEL- I THINK FOR ALL OF US
WHO ARE CO CHAIRS WORKING OF
DONE BEEN DONE WITHOUT THE-
MEDICAL STAFF. AT AND BOTH
HOUSES SO I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK-
SO LET'S BRING UP THE FIRST
PANEL WHICH IS. THE COMPLETE
COUNT SIX CENSUS OFFICE WE
HAVE- SERRA. SO TAYLOR DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF FOR CENSUS FROM
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
AND SONYA LOG MEN CHIEF OF
STAFF CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
STATE CENSUS OFFICE WELCOME.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
YOUR PRESENTATIONS. ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING IN DURING
NEXT FEW WEEKS OR EVEN TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR INVITING US TODAY
TO SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT LAST
CALL THE FINAL COUNTDOWN TO
CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY. IS THERE
A SET A TAILOR AND THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF CENSUS FOR THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
AND I'M JOINED TODAY BY MY
COLLEAGUE. SONIA LOG MEN OUR
CHIEF OF STAFF FOR THE CENSUS
OFFICE. THIS IS OUR SEVEN
HEARING- ENGAGEMENT AND THE
FINAL OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH
YOU AT THE DATES WITH THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE BEFORE AT THE
COUNT STARTS. AS IS IT
REITERATED THIS MORNING THIRTY
DAYS LESS THAN THIRTY DAYS.
INTEL FROM NOW UNTIL MARCH
TWELFTH WHEN THE EMPTIES WILL
BE MAILED. AND TO COMPLETE THE
CENSUS QUESTIONNAIRE ONLINE. AT
THE REQUEST OF STAFF WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TO PRESENT. AN UPDATE
SINCE OUR LAST OCTOBER TWENTY
NINETEEN QUARTERLY REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE. AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I KNOW I ONLY
HAVE A FEW MINUTES. I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY HIGHLIGHTING SOME KEY
DELIVERABLES. THANK RIGHT TO
THE HEART OF OUR MISSION THAT
IS ENSURING THAT THE HARDEST TO
COUNT CALIFORNIANS ARE COUNTED.
OUR WORK IS DEFINED BY THREE
QUARTER ORGANIZATIONAL. KILLERS
COORDINATION COLLABORATION AND
COMMUNICATION. AND FIRST IN THE
VEIN OF PARTNER COORDINATION
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE
HELD TWENTY STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WORKSHOPS
WE FINALIZED AND APPROVED ALL.
PARTNER STRATEGIC PLANS PROVED
ALL IMPLEMENTATION PLANS THAT
INCLUDE SEVENTY SEVEN COUNTY
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THIRTY SIX
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS. WE'VE
DISTRIBUTED GUIDANCE AROUND
QUESTIONNAIRE ASSISTANCE
CENTERS AND KIOSKS CANVAS
SEEING AND PHONE BANKING AND
INCENTIVE PURCHASES. WE BUILT A
STRONGER COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP KEEP ALL
OF OUR PARTNERS APPRAISED.
APPRISED OF THE MANY MOVING
PARTS WE HAVE BY ADDING REGULAR
BI WEEKLY CALLS TO THE
PARTNERS. A WEEKLY ELECTRONIC
NEWSLETTER AND WEBINARS TO
PROVIDE TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES.
AS THE SECOND LARGEST COMPONENT
OF OUR WORK WE CRAFTED A MEDIA
STRATEGY AND BEGAN TO AIR IN
MARKET. WE WERE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT OUR MEDIA BY. GIVEN THE
DIVERSITY OF THE AUDIENCE WE
ARE TRYING TO REACH AND THE
COMPLICATIONS OF THE POLITICAL
WINDOW. WE HAD TO STRETCH HER
DOLLARS AS FAR AS POSSIBLE BY
BEING STRATEGIC. WE STARTED
WITH THE STATEWIDE MEDIA BY.
AND THEN THREE FURTHER
REFINEMENT AND INFORMATION
ABOUT WHERE WE NEED TO FILL IN
CRAFTED A PLAN THAT WORKS FOR
EACH OF OUR TEN REGION'S. YOU
HEAR MORE FROM MERCURY AND THE
NEXT PANEL. BUT SINCE THE END
OF AUGUST WHEN THEY WERE FULLY
ON BOARDED. THEY HAVE BEEN
RUNNING AND RUNNING FAST TO
COMPLETE THE WORK. AND LASTLY
WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ALL
OF THIS WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
IS ROOTED IN DATA. WE HAVE A
LEVERAGED ARE CALIFORNIA HARD
TO COUNT INDEX. TO FOCUS ON
WHAT CENSUS TRACKS ARE LIKELY
TO REPRESENT CALIFORNIANS WITH
THE MOST BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATING IN THE CENSUS. SO
WE CALL OUR ONLINE TOOL SOARED
THE STATE WIDE OUT REGION RAPID
DEPLOYMENT THIS IS GOING TO
ALLOW US AND CONTINUES TO ALLOW
US TO ANALYZE CENSUS TRACT
DATA. ENDED SPECIFIC
CHARACTERISTICS IN THE CENSUS
TRACKS AND IN ADDITION TO
MAKING DECISIONS USING THIS
TOOL WE ARE ASKING PARTNERS TO
USE IT AS THE UNIFYING TRACKING
MECHANISM FOR THEIR ACTIVITIES
THAT WOULD THEIR CURRENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND
THAT'S ALLOWING US TO MONITOR
THOSE INVESTMENTS THIS ALLOWS
TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO ADDRESS
ANY AREAS WHERE THERE WILL BE A
LOW RESPONSE RATE AND REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THROUGH
THE NON RESPONSE FOLLOW AT
PERIOD. AND SPEAKING OF
RESOURCES WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
DESIRE BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE HAVE
ALLOCATED THE REMAINING BALANCE
OF OUR FRIENDS. THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATED TO S. THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ALLOCATION
DECISIONS WERE BASED ON VARIOUS
DELIVERABLES THAT WE HAVE IN
HOUSE THIS NOTABLY THE REPORTS
THAT WERE PROVIDED BY OUR
CONTRACTED PARTNERS AS WELL AS
THE IMPLEMENTATION PLANS THAT
WERE SUBMITTED TO US. OUR
CALIFORNIA'S CENSUS OFFICE
LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS PLANNED AS WELL AS THE
ANALYSIS OF THE MOST RECENT
AMERICAN COMMUNITY SURVEY DATA.
WE ANALYZED INSIGHTS FROM OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. AND DEVELOP
FORMULAS TO DETERMINE THE
FUNDING LEVELS. IN FOLLOWING
FOR PRIORITY AREAS. FIRST WE
RECOGNIZE THERE IS A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR PRINTING.
NINETEEN TO ENSURE THAT
COLLATERAL MATERIALS ARE
AVAILABLE TO COMPLEMENT THE OUT
REACH STRATEGIES ON THE GROUND.
PROVIDING IN LANGUAGE SUPPORT
AS NECESSARY TO MEET OUR
LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS PLAN. AND ALSO ADDING
ACTIVITIES ARE SCALING EXISTING
ACTIVITIES TO PRIORITY CENSUS
TRACKS THERE ARE FIFTY SEVEN OR
ABOVE IN OUR INDEX. AND LASTLY
ESTABLISH CONTINGENCY FUND FOR
RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF RESOURCES
TO FURTHER INVEST IN TRACKS
THAT HAVE BELOW AVERAGE
RESPONSE RATES. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THESE DOLLARS MAKE
THEIR WAY TO THE COMMUNITY FAST
AND BASED ON FEEDBACK THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM OUR PARTNERS WE
STREAMLINED ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES TO MOVE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IN FRONT LOW DECISION
MAKING. AS WE MOVED INTO
DECISIONS AND DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE FINAL ALLOCATIONS WE TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE
CAPACITY. OF OUR CONTRACTED
PARTNERS WE CREATED A PROCESS
THAT ALLOWS FOR TRANSPARENCY AS
WELL AS COLLABORATION. ENGAGING
WITH OUR PARTNERS TO HELP US
DETERMINE WHAT ORGANIZATIONS
ARE BEST SUITED FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS. WE PROVIDED A
PRELIMINARY UPDATE ON THESE
ALLOCATIONS TODAY IT'S A BLUE
CHART THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE IN
YOUR FOLDER IN FRONT OF YOU AND
THIS IS A KEY UPDATE FROM OUR
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE REPORT THAT WAS
SUBMITTED TO YOU. ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AGO. PLEASE NOTE THAT
THESE ARE NOT FINAL. AS
CONTRACTS ARE STILL BEING
RECEIVED AND SEVERAL ARE
PENDING FINAL APPROVAL FROM
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. WE
ANTICIPATE THAT ALL EXECUTED
CONTRACTS WILL BE COMPLETED BY
THE END OF FEBRUARY. AND IN OUR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO ENSURE
THAT DOLLARS REACH PARTNERS IN
A TIMELY FASHION RE RELEASED A
10% WITH WHOLE PROVISION IN
CONTRACTS EARLY. STREAMLINED
THE DELIVERABLE PROCESS FOR
THIS LAST ROUND OF FUNDING AND
CONTINUE TO MOVE THROUGH
INVOICES ON A ROLLING BASIS.
SEVEN CLOSING WHEN I THINK YOU
SO MUCH FOR INVESTING TIME IN
THE HEARING FROM US TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE CRITICAL
OUTREACH EFFORTS YOU AND YOUR
STAFF HAVE UNDERTAKEN ON BEHALF
OF THE HARDEST ACCOUNT
CALIFORNIANS WE VALUE YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND YOUR SUPPORT.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. BUT
WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE END
OF THE PANEL THAT I WAS LIKE
MAN. WELCOME THANK YOU DOCTOR
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
PREPARED FOR THE PRESENTATION.
DALY ADDITIONAL PRESENTATION
RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AND US AS SOME NUMBERS
OUT IF I COULD START- YOU
MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
MEDIA BY- WITH SPECIFIC PLANS-
ALL WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE
AREA OF MICRO TARGETING AS A
OUR HEART HOW TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES. IF ANY. COURSE
THANK YOU SIR- MERCURY YEAH OUR
COMMUNICATIONS VENDOR AND IS
HERE TODAY AND WILL BE PART OF
THE SECOND PANEL BUT JUST TO
SPEAK AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL
ABOUT. I'M A BIT OF OUR
STRATEGY AROUND THIS PARTICULAR
AREA- AS SARAH HAD MENTIONED
YOU KNOW ALL OF THE WORK THAT
WE ARE DOING IS ROOTED AND
DATA- AND THAT IS THROUGH HOW
ARE INDEX IS VISUALIZED INA
CHORE IN A TOOL. THAT WE
LOVINGLY REFER TO AS SOARED-
ANOTHER ONE FOR THE MIX OF FUN
THINGS TO TAKE BACK- WE DID
TAKE THAT INDEX ME OVERLY
DESIGNATED MARKETING AREAS- AND
THEN WHAT OUTLETS MAY BE MOST
APPROPRIATE AND TO REACH THE
HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITY THAT
MAY BE RELEVANT AND THAT
PARTICULAR TRACK- SO REALLY
TRYING TO LAYER ALL OF THOSE
PIECES. AND TO BE AS- SURGICAL
AS POSSIBLE- TO REACHING THE
COMMUNITY SO IF IT YOU KNOW
WE'RE AT. FOR EXAMPLE CHINESE
SPEAKING COMMUNITY WHAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE- MEDIUM YOU KNOW
THAT VIA TELEVISION IS IT VIA
PRINT- AND IT IS THE BEST
SLAVERY OF IN LANGUAGE- AS OUR-
STRATEGY DOES TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT- BACK COMPLEXITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY. IN OUR
MARKETING CAMPAIGN WILL BE
PRODUCED IN THIRTEEN LANGUAGES.
GOT IT THANK YOU OF COURSE.
SOME MISS THANK YOU A STRUCTURE
AND- I'M NOT SURE THIS IS THE
PANEL ASKED THIS OR MAYBE THE
NEXT ONE AS FAR AS THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE ALLOCATIONS
OF MONEY THAT'S GOING TO THE
BOARDS HOW MANY ACTUALLY-
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS
APPROVED ALLOCATION UNDER THE
PLAN THAT'S BEEN SUBMITTED TO A-
AND HOW MANY ARE STILL OUT
THERE. THAT WE NEED TO GET THEM
TO ACCEPT THIS PLAN. SO THEN
YOU ALLOCATION OF DOLLARS- IT
WAS A PROCESS IN WHICH WE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE COUNTY AS
WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
SAID TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
COUNTY SAID YES WE WOULD LIKE
TO USE THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THEY'RE ALL IN A VERY
DIFFERENT SCHEDULE WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT TODAY A LOT OF
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ARE HAVING- HEARING SUCH AS
THIS IN ORDER TO APPROVE. THE
ADDITIONAL USE OF THOSE DOLLARS
AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH AN UPDATED CHART AS WE
RECEIVE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE OUTCOMES OF THOSE HEARINGS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THANK YOU
THAT WOULD BE VERY INFORMATIVE
ESPECIALLY THE TO COUNTY THAT
WE REPRESENT THE MAYBE WE
COULD. GET ENGAGED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS MOVING FORWARD AND
ALSO- WITH THE- HAND OUT TO SEA
THAT THE NATIVE AMERICANS ARE
HARD TO COUNT AREAS. AND WE SEE
AND HEAR THAT MANY NATIVE
AMERICANS ALSO BELIEVE THE LACK
OF AGENCY TO TRULY INFLUENCE
DECISIONS SO HOW ARE WE NOW
WORKING- WITH FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES BUT ALSO. THE
URBAN POPULATION OF NATIVE
AMERICANS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE BEING COUNTED IN THE
CENSUS. WE'RE SO EAGER WE- ARE
VERY FORTUNATE- FOR THE
INVESTMENT THAT YOU ALL HAVE
PROVIDED TO THINK YOU AND I
THINK WITH THAT- WE HAVE
CREATED A TEAM- OF NOT ONLY
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES%
THAT HAS HAVE OPTED IN TO SERVE
AS TRUSTED MESSENGERS AND SO
FAR AS THEIR GOVERNMENT ENTITY
ITSELF- BUT WE'VE ALSO
CONTRACTED. WITH FOUR OTHER
CORD TEAM MEMBERS WHO ARE
NATIVE AMERICAN AND TRIBAL
OUTREACH STRATEGY- AND WE ARE
ALSO FORTUNATE ENOUGH THAT THE
GOVERNOR APPOINTED I'M A SOLE
PERSON ON OUR TEAM. I'M OUR
TRAVEL ADVISOR- KAYLA HOW ARE
YOU WHO'S BEEN A WONDERFUL
ADDITION- TO HELP COORDINATE
THOSE FOR- DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS- RECOGNIZING THAT
WHERE OUR DATA IS RELATIVE TO
HARD TO COUNT. BUT REALLY
RELYING ON ALL OF THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS THROUGH I'M HERE
CALIFORNIA NEED A VOTE PRODUCT
PROJECT- AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA
INDIAN MANPOWER- ASSOCIATION
AND SO REALLY MAKING SURE THAT
YOU KNOW IF HARD TO COUNT ME
LOOK LIKE IT IS HERE. WE REALLY
KNOW THE- MAYBE AND HOURS AWAY.
BUT IS JUST AS EMPOWER. I'M SO
IN. NOT ELEMENT OUR TRUSTED
MESSENGERS INTO THE ACTUAL
STRATEGY THAT WE EXECUTE.
SOUNDS GOOD IT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK BEING
DONE. IN A NOTICE THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF. TRIBES HAVE OPTED IN-
SO WHAT WHAT DOES THAT REALLY
MEAN WHEN THEY SAY THEY OPTED
IN IS IT INTO THE THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN. THOUSAND HOURS OR
OTHER THAT OTHER MONEY THAT'S
ALLOCATED FOR TRIBES- IN THE
HARD TO COUNT AREAS. SO I SEE
THE- IN THE HAND OUT IN THE
MATERIAL. THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
TRIBES THAT HAVE OPTED IN THERE
SOME THAT AREN'T BUT LOT OF
THESE ARE FOR A RECOGNIZED
TRIBES. SO HOW ARE THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE URBAN AREAS-
STILL BEING ABLE TO- GETTING
CASE AND THAT TYPE OF FUNDING
AND- THAT RESOURCES OUT THERE.
SO THERE IS SO THERE'S TIãU
CONTRACTORS THAT SONYA
MENTIONED- THERE'S THE FOLKS
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING-
THE AVERAGE DIRECTLY AND RE
ALLOCATING SOME OF THOSE
DOLLARS TO THE FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES SO THAT'S
WHEN YOU SEE THE OPT. IN THE ON
THE HILL TO THE POT OF THE
MONEY THE THREE SIXTEEN OR- YES
IN SAID AND SO THOSE THAT DID
NOT OPT IN THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE
THEY WILL STILL BE RECEIVING.
OUTREACH EFFORTS THE WILL BE
RECEIVING THE OUTREACH EFFORTS
FROM THAT UMBRELLA
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE HAVE- IN
ADDITION TO THAT YOUR CORRECT
THERE ARE- ARE NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION RESIDES IN. URBAN
AREAS AS WELL SO WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA- ANY OF A PROJECT
OVER NEAR THE WHO IS DOING A
LOT OF WORK IN THE URBAN AREAS
IN ORDER TO DO THAT OUT REACH.
AND THEY ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ALSO CONTRACTED WITH NOONE.
SOONER IS OUR MARKETING FIRM
THAT IS BEING VERY STRATEGIC
AND HER GETTING THE NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION TO ALSO DO
OUR REACH AND COMPLEMENT THE
WORK. OF THESE TWO CONTRACTED
VENDORS. AND THEY'RE ON THE
NEXT PANEL RIGHT IS THAT. ALL I
DON'T TO LEARN A IS NOT MERCURY
IS ON THE NEXT PANEL THAT THEY
CAN SPEAK TO SOME OF THE CORE
NEEDED WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
WITH NEW AND- SOON AS A VERY
SPECIALIZED NEED OF HIM. AGAIN
MARKETING FIRM. IT IS ONE OF
THE FOR THAT TO AN AND
CLARIFIES THAT CALIFORNIA.
REMAINS THE NUMBER ONE- STATE
WITH EIGHT AMERICAN- POPULATION
IN THE WHOLE UNITED STATES SO
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CONTINUES TO BE COUNTED IN ALL
AREAS FEDERAL RECOGNIZED
TRIBES. IN IRVINE TRAVEL TO
THEIR LIVING URBAN A CENTER.
THANK YOU TILE CAN. MR MY
QUESTION IS REGARDING EGGMAN
DURING YOUR OPENING THE ROLE OF
INVOICES AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO ASK- YEAH WHAT IT WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
SEEN WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE
WHAT IS THAT PROGRAM LOOK LIKE
AND WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT IF ANY AT THE
FEW ENCOUNTERED ALONG THAT
PROCESS OR HAPPY TO REPORT-
THAT ONCE THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS WERE SUBMITTED TO US THAT
WAS THE SORT OF THE LAST BIG
DELIVERABLE FOR US AND THEN
INVOICES WERE RECEIVED SHORTLY
THERE AFTER FROM ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS. TO THEM BERNIE OF OUR
PARTNERS HAVE 290% OF THE
FUNDING THAT ORIGINAL FUNDING
HAS ALREADY IN THEIR HANDS- I
THINK THIS ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
WHAT WE HAVE CONTINUOUS DONE
CAN TO OUR PARTNER THAT TO
SUBMIT THE INVOICES IN A TIMELY
MANNER- AND ALSO TO THE RIGHT
LOCATION I THINK THAT'S WHERE
WE A LITTLE BIT OF HICK UPS THE
LESSONS LEARNED WE HAD MANY
LESS LEARNED WE ARE DOT IN THEM
AS HIS QB KEY. AND BEING A YOUR
MIND AIMING AT THE END SO YOU
SIMILAR OVER. THE DELAY WAS
APPROVED SUBMIT YOUR IN. AND
THEN WE CAN GO AHEAD MAKE THAT
PAYMENT. SOME OF THE OTHER SORT
OF IT MIGHT OF. THAT WE'VE MADE
TO THE PROCESS ALSO
STREAMLINING INTERNALLY SOME OF
THE TRACKING MECHANISMS THAT
WE'VE PUT INTO PLACE- THIS LAST
GO AROUND ALSO WE WERE. WE WERE
VERY CONCERNED JUST- AND SHARE
YOUR YOUR- PRIORITIES ABOUT
GETTING THE DOLLARS OUT SO WE
DID. HEY EXTRA TO HAVE-
EXPEDITED PAYMENT IS ST
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE FOR THAT
LAST- BIG INVOICE WHICH WAS THE
DELIVERABLE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. AND THE
ANSWERS ARE QUESTION. WHAT IS A
SHORT CHALLENGE WITH THE
REMAINDER THAT THE 10% HE SAID
90% HAS SO- SO THERE'S TWO
DELIVERABLES THAT ARE LEFT. I
PERCENT IS THE NURSE WHO
PLANNED THE NON RESPONSE FOLLOW
UP PERIOD WE JUST- HAD A
PRESENTATION WE HAD A WEAPON
ARE WITH OUR PARTNERS TO HELP
THEM KIND OF WALK THROUGH WHAT
WE WOULD WANT TO SEE AND THAT
NON RESPONSE FOLLOW UP
DELIVERABLE IT'S A PLAN THAT
OUTLINES SOME OF THE FIVE SOME
OF YOUR PRIORITIES HOW WILL YOU
BE ABLE TO RESPOND DURING THE
SELF RESPONSE PERIOD. THAT IS
WORTH 5% LAST 5% IS THE FINAL
FINAL REPORT SO- THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD TO THAT-
SO IT'S A THAT PART OF THE TINY
THE REMAINING. BEING. AND ASA
YES. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
SO TO YOU'RE US A REAP ON ON
THE OUT REGION. I WHAT I. DON'T
YET OR IS THE- OF. WHAT IS THE
OUTRAGE THAT HAS BEEN DONE. ON
IN THIS IS BEEN WORKED ON FOR A
REALLY REALLY LONG TIME AND I
REMEMBER FROM PAST HEARINGS. WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT NOT
ONLY WAS THE MONEY OUT BUDGETED
BUT MONEY GOT INTO THE HANDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAD LOTS OF
TESTIMONY FROM COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS EVERYWHERE FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO UP AND
DOWN THE STATE ALL THE ISSUES
ALL THE CONCERNS. SO I STILL
DON'T I STILL CAN'T GET THE OR
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM YOU WHAT
HAVE WE DONE AS FAR AS
IMPLEMENTING THE OUT REACH WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE FIELD. OF
AND- I'M NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR
MATH TO UP. HOW MUCH DID. THE
THAT WE'VE BEEN GIVEN OUT. TO
DO OUTREACH HOW MUCH IS THAT
AND- YOU KNOW IT IS IT WORKING
BECAUSE HERE WE ARE THREE WEEKS.
THIS IS WE BAD HEARINGS WE'VE
HAD TESTIMONY ALL THIS SO I
DON'T HAVE A SENSE OF. WHERE
WERE AT THREE WEEKS FROM THE
START. OR FOUR WEEKS FROM THE
START I'M HAPPY TO START AND
THEN- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY SIR
CAN HELP FILL IN- HERE JUST TO
GIVE A HIGH LEVEL- PICTURE- YOU
KNOW THE WAY THAT WE ARE DOING
THE WORK- WE ARE TARGETING-
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN FOR
CALIFORNIANS- THAT ARE THE
HARDEST TO COUNT SO THAT IS
THAT INDEX THAT WE'VE REFERRED
TO IT AS SOMETHING UNIQUE.
FORMULA THAT WE REALLY USE DOES
THAT IS FOR THAT DATA I'M
TAKING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I BELIEVE- AND THAT. BACK
FROM STAFF YOU HAVE A LITTLE
MAP IN THERE TO REFER TO- JUST
TO POINT THAT OUT- AND IT WILL
SHOW YOU HOW THOSE TEN REGIONS
ARE DIVIDED- AND SO WITH THAT
WORK SORT OF THE FIRST SLAYER-
IS REALLY THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COMMUNITY BENEFIT-
ORGANIZATION- WHO IS HELPING
TO. COURT ACTIVITIES ON THAT
ARE HAPPENING IN ANY GIVEN
REGION- YOU BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF OUR STATE. I'M
BOTH WITH POPULATION IN
GEOGRAPHY AND SO ON- THEY ARE
MUCH DIFFERENT. I'M FOR EXAMPLE
REGION EIGHT- LOS ANGELES IT IS
THE COUNTY IN AND OF ITSELF- AS
WELL AS THE SINGLE COUNTY WHERE
IS IN REGION ONE- IT IT. IT IS
THE RETURN WHICH IS COMPRISED
OF THAN SEVENTEEN COUNTIES. AND
SO YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT EACH OF. ARE
ORGANIZING OF LAYERS HAVE IN
COORDINATION ARE DIFFERENT AND
UNIQUE- SO WE REALLY KNOWLEDGE
THAT YOU KNOW I COME FROM THE
SPACE FOR I GOT TO WORK- WITH
FAIR GROUNDS. AND WHILE THEY
ARE SO SIMILAR THEY ARE ALSO
UNIQUE- AND SO INCREASING THAT
UNIQUENESS- EACH OF THOSE-
REGIONS- THEN PARTNER WITH. FOR
EXAMPLE THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WHICH WE'VE MADE AN
OVER SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. IN DIRECT. SHOW YOU
THE P. I'M AS WELL AS STATEWIDE
COMMUNITY. WERE THAT ARE FOR ON
THIS. POPULATION THAT ME WITHIN
A HARD TO COME. AND SO THERE
REALLY CA. AND DO. THE WORK SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN REGION FOR-
THERE IS A FABULOUS PROGRAM-
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
CAN SPEAK TO- WHERE FOLKS HAVE
YOU KNOW ALREADY BEEN ON THE
GROUND CALLING- CLEANING LIST.
IF YOU WILL OF HOUSEHOLDS ON TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION TO
PREPARE ON AS I UNDERSTAND
THEY'VE MADE OVER A MILLION
PHONE CALLS- OVER TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND TO HELP EDUCATE
THE COMMUNITY AND REGION FOUR-
BUT REALLY I'M TO HELP PREPARE
THEM FOR THE ACTUAL CAL MAKING
SURE THAT THEY GET EARLY
EDUCATION MATERIAL THAT HAS
BEEN THE FOCUS. GOING TO THE-
I'M JUST SURE IN UNITY WHAT THE
IS NOT ON THE RE THAT WE HAVE
DONE THAT THAT IS A CHANCE
OMINOUS WHAT CEREMONY AND ON. I
NEED TO JUMP IN. I UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE WE GONE IT LOTS TIMES
WHAT WE WERE TARGETING WHY WE
WERE TARGETING HOW HOW SPECIFIC
PARTS OF THE STATE WHY LANGUAGE
YOU NAME. I'M LOOKING FOR WHAT
HAVE WE CONCRETE LEE. WHAT KIND
OF OUTREACH HAVE WE DONE UP
UNTIL NOW JUST A FEW WEEKS AWAY
FROM THE YOU GAVE ME AN EXAMPLE
OF SOMETHING THAT A PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATIONS DOING BUT CAN WE
SAY WE'VE SPENT A HUNDRED OR
WE'VE GIVEN OUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS IS HOW
MUCH CONTACT WE HAVE MADE IN
THOSE HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES
I I'M I'M JUST NOT GETTING HERE
WHAT I THOUGHT WE WOULD HAVE BY
NOW AS FAR AS ON A LOT OF MONEY
GETTING OUT TO A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS DID HE GET OUT.
DID YOU GET OUT IN TIME OR YOU
KNOW I JUST DON'T HAVE A SENSE
YET SO LET ME LET ME JUST ADD
TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS AS ANYA
MADE ABOUT THE ACTUAL WORK
THAT'S BEING CONDUCTED ON THE
GROUND SEC WE NEED AT THIS THE
POPULATION LIVES WE'VE BASED ON
THE CENSUS. WE ALSO IT'S NOT A
ONE TOUCH AND DONE SO ON
AVERAGE IT'LL PROBABLY TAKE
ABOUT TWELVE OVER ACTIONS
PRESSURE BY OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS SO WITH THESE BINGE
BEING IS THE REAL. PASSED I
NOW. THE YOU LOOK EMPLOYEE.
CHEN IN THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
CAN I NOW IN PER. TO DOING CAN
TO. IT'S A VARIETY OF. IT COULD
BE I'M GOING TO THE TO. ON
SUNDAY TO DO A SERMON IN FRONT
IT'S ALSO CANVASSING IT'S THE
PHONE BANKING IT'S THE EVENTS
IT'S BEING AT THE SCHOOLS IT'S
GOING TO OTHER COMMUNITY BASED.
ON EVENTS THAT ARE HAPPENING I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THROUGH THE
REPORTING MECHANISM THAT MAY
HAVE. BIRD IN WHICH WE UPLOAD
IT ALL OF THE ACTIVITIES. OF
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE BEING
CONDUCTED. OUT OF ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY THERE
THEY'RE ALL THEY'RE GOING TO BE
REPORTING ON THE NUMBER OF
IMPRESSIONS SO ONCE THEY ARE
DONE WITH THE EVENT. THEY ARE
BEING ASKED REQUIRED TO REPORT
HOW PRECIOUS BELIEVE HE- AT THE
EVENT. IF THIS TURNS THE HER TO
KILL HI. HOW MANY OF THEM WERE
THEY- SO TO GET TO THE- NUMBERS
WE CONTINUE TO THOSE NUMBERS
UPDATED- AND WE WERE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE TO GET
MORE SPECIFICS ON HOW MANY
ACTIVITIES ARE HAPPENING IN AND
GEOGRAPHIC AREA. WE DO WE DO
HAVE RESOURCE TO THE TOOLS IN
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO MONITOR.
OKAY MAYBE I'M NOT MAKING MY OF
CLEAR. I DON'T KNOW WHY WE
CAN'T GET TODAY FROM YOU THOSE
NUMBERS. IF YOU YOU KNOW I'M
SURE THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUBMITTING
THIS TO YOU OR YOU WOULD SAY
SOME OF THE MARIN SOME OF THEM
AREN'T SOMEWHERE FAILING. I
JUST. I WANT TO KNOW FOR ALL
THE MONEY THAT HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED. WHAT KIND OF OUT
REGION CONTACT HAVE WE MADE
WITH HOW MANY PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I. EIGHT EIGHT YOU
KNOW YOU'VE GOT METRICS I
UNDERSTAND I RESPECT ALL THE
WAYS IN WHICH OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE REACHING OUT. BUT DO WE
KNOW NOW THAT WE'VE TALKED TO.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
TEN MILLION PEOPLE WERE OF A
STATE OF FORTY MILLION WHO
INVESTED A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS. WHAT A.
HAVE WE DONE TO. COME WITH.
VERY TO DO THIS. IS OF THE WORK
ON THIS I JUST. KNOW WHY WE CAN
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF WHERE
WE'RE AT. QUESTION THE QUESTION
RIGHT F. A. PRECIADO THE
QUESTION I KNOW THAT- AND BABY
YOU CAN FOLLOW UP- WITH THE
SENATOR- LEADERS WELL- IN IN A
WAY THIS IS KELLY DO TV SO I
GUESS IS THAT- I DAY I OR-
THAT'S THE PERIL FOR ALL OF US
WHO ARE ELECTED OFFICE- AND-
SO. I KNOW HAVE YOU SEEN A
DEMONSTRATION OF SOARED- AND I
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT IT
LATER THAT- YEAH THERE I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES NERD THAN THEIR
ALSO. HELP TENS OF. TALK ABOUT
HOW WE FEEL EVERYTHING FOR.
DIFFERENT IT'S A SELF. I THINK
SO THE HARD TO MISS A- CAP.
EVERYTHING US. WAY BECAUSE AND
THEN WE HAVE EACH OF THE A CBO
ARE WORKING WITH FIRST
COMMUNITY GROUPS HAVE DIFFERENT
STRATEGY SO- BUT HOPEFULLY WE
CAN GET A BETTER SENSE AND
ALSO- WE TALK ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS- AND THEY TALK
ABOUT SOME THE COMMUNICATION
METRICS AS WELL- BUT- SO I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT BECAUSE I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS LATER BY
THOSE OTHER PEOPLE QUESTIONS.
TO ME SO A SOME MEMBER LORENA
ALSO WELCOME AND I SOMEONE
WORKING ON SOME EVER CITY COME
LIKE A DOVE AND THE CENTER
CUBBY EL AND I KNOW. CENTER
BECAUSE ALSO HAS A QUESTION I
DON'T KNOW OR I WANNA LIVE ON
WHAT SENATOR DEVICES SET. A
LITTLE. IN CERTAIN. I HER.
THINK WE NEED TWELVE TOUCHES TO
GET AT THE PEOPLE TO ACT OUR
HOW MANY AT THIS. WHAT WAS THE
EXPERT HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
THEY HAD ONE TOUCH OUR THE
COMMUNITIES I LIVE IN A HARD TO
COUNT COMMUNITY AND I GOTTA SAY
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING- I I'VE
BEEN TOUCHED SIX TIMES BY THE
BERNIE SANDERS CAMPAIGN AND
I'VE BEEN SUCH ONCE BY CENSUS
RIGHT. I'M WONDERING LIKE OUR
WHICH TEAM LIKE. AT THIS POINT
WE SHOULD OF TOUCH THIS
COMMUNITY TWICE ARE ARE WE-
HAVE A PLAN ON WHEN THAT TWELVE
TOUCH COMES THEN YOU KNOW DO WE
DO WE ACTUALLY BREAK IT DOWN TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS LIKE YOU SAID
WERE USED TO LIKE IDENTIFYING.
ADDRESSES IN PEOPLE OR IS THIS
LIKE WELL THIS MANY PEOPLE AND
SOME COMMUNITY HAS BEEN TOUCHED
AND WE DON'T KNOW BE TOUCH ONCE
IN WHOLE BE TOUCH TWENTY FOUR
TIMES. JUST WONDERING ON KIND
OF THAT DATA DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE. DO WE HAVE ANYTHING ON
THAT. SEC SO I THINK WORRY ARE
EIGHT NOW AND- WE HAVE METRIC
SURROUNDED THE MEDIA WE HAVE
METRICS AROUND THE MEDIA YES
REYES WE HAVE CLICK THROUGH
RATES WE CAN SEE THE
IMPRESSIONS BY THE RADIO-
SOCIAL MEDIA X. CENTER WE HAVE
THE IMPRESSIONS THAT OUR OUR
COMMUNITY- ORGANIZATIONS ARE
DOING THROUGH THEIR OUTRAGE ON
THE GROUND ACTIVITIES. PUT THE
TOGETHER WE WILL BE PUTTING
TOGETHER THE WAY WE'RE GOING TO
BE PUTTING THEM TOGETHER WILL
COME VERY QUICKLY ONCE WE- ONCE
FOR IN THAT THAT RESPONSE
PERIOD BECAUSE WE WILL ALSO BE
MEASURING. HOW THE RESPONSE
RATES ARE COMING IN TO THE
RESPONSE RATES CAN MEN WE WILL
BE LOOKING AT THE TWENTY TO
RESPONSE RATES COMPARISON THOSE
JUST SEE. HAVE WE MADE ANY GAME
ARE ON TARGET ARE WE BEHIND- SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE DATA POINTS SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE IT JUST ST. G. SET WE
CAN'T THAT ONE PARTICULAR SET
PRACTICE TIME HAS BEEN. HI YOUR-
IN TOUCH IS BIG. THE POPULATION
IS SO DE. WE'RE TRYING REACH
THE POP. WHERE THEY LIVE WORK
FOR A PLAY SO THEY MAY BE
RECEIVING. TWO IMPRESSIONS THAT
DAY BECAUSE- IN HEARING ON THE
RADIO AND THEY'RE GOING TO
THEIR SCHOOL IN HEARING IT FROM
THE TEACHER. SO IT'S HARD TO
MEASURE HOW MANY. ONE PERSON
HAS SEEN BUT WHAT WE CAN DO AS
A CENSUS TRACT WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT IT IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE REACHING THE
COMMUNITIES BOTH ON THE GROUND
TO THE TRUSTED MESSENGERS AS
WELL AS IN THE AIR. ANYTHING
JUST ADD TO THAT- WE HAVE
FOCUSED- THE DIFFERENT TEAMS ON
TWO PARALLEL WITH PEAK
OPERATIONS RELATIVES. ACTUALLY
AND SAID YOU'RE A CREATION NOT
TO ME I'M SO SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS TO QUESTIONS IT
BELIEVE. THERE IS A TRUE
INDUSTRY STAND FOR WHAT WE ARE
DOING BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA WE
LOVE TO BE PIE. HOWEVER YOU
RECOGNIZING THAT THE FEDERAL
CENSUS BUREAU IS DOING ITS OWN
WORK RELATIVE TO ITS PAID BY-
TRUTH TAKING THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION LOOKING AT OUR
INVESTMENT- RELATIVE TO OUR OWN
PAID BY WHICH YOU HEAR MORE
ABOUT. WHERE IT REALLY
COMMUNICATION HAS STARTED VIA
PAID MEDIA BUYS BUT REALLY
STARTS TO RAMP UP- WHEN PEOPLE
ASK. IF THAT VACATION FROM THE
CENTERS- MADE MARK WITH OF PEAK
PACKED YOU THROUGH WHAT WILL
CALL THE BEGINNING OF SINCE THE
SEASON- MID MARCH TO THE END OF
APRIL. ON AND THAT CONTINUE TO
HOPEFULLY FOLKS AND UNION
SHOULD SOMEONE AT. THE DOOR I'M
WHO AND IT IS AN BERMAN WE
NOTED THE WORK OUT LANCE B. AND
WE IN YOU BEING WITH THEM. BUT.
VISIBILITY. STATE OF POINTS AND
I SER MENTION WE CONTINUE TO
PUSH FOLKS TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE THAT- ONCE THE COUNT- DOES
CONCLUDE THAT WE DO HAVE THAT
VERY CLEAR PICTURE- ESPECIALLY
RELATIVE TO- RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR TWENTY THIRTY OF ALL OF THE
AMAZING THINGS THAT DID WORK.
ON AND WERE EFFECTIVE IN
REACHING OUT COMMUNITIES. OKAY.
CENTER I'M BURKE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK ALL
THE MEMBERS WHO HAVE JOINED
HERE TODAY AS SOMEONE MENTIONED
EARLIER IT'S QUITE IMPRESSIVE
HOW MANY FOLKS FROM THE TWO
HOUSES HAVE APPEARED OF FIRST
STEP THANK YOU TO SENATOR ALSO
CENTER ALSO LED THE EFFORT IN
TERMS OF RESOURCES THROUGH THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR WHEN
SHE WHEN SHE WOULD SHARE AND
WHAT. ABOUT THE- WERE. I'M
TRICKS PERFORMANCE MEASURE AND
I KNOW THE WAS BEFORE YOU WERE
A PART OF THE SENSES PROGRAM
BUT FALLING ON FROM ASSEMBLY
LORETTA GETS FLETCHER IS
QUESTIONS ALSO BOB PERHAPS IF
YOU COULD SHARE WITH US WHAT
YOUR METRICS ARE IN YOUR
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT IS SO FOR EXAMPLE
THIS IS A POINTS UP THERE IF.
OF YOU EXT OF YOU KNOW TOUCHES
PER PERSON BY THIS TIME HAVE
YOU DONE A SURVEY HAVE YOU MET
THAT IF YOU HAVEN'T MET THAT
WHAT ARE YOU DOING THAT TERMS
OF HIRING WHAT IS YOUR
PERFORMED WANNA HIRE TEN PEOPLE
BY THE- FAR WITH SEVEN WHERE
ARE YOU ON YOUR PERFORMANCE MAY
ARE YOU ON YOUR. SO WE'RE IT. I
CAN HEAR FROM ALL QUESTIONS OF
VERY IN IS TO WHERE YOU ARE
THOSE THINGS. I DON'T EXPECT TO
TELL US ALL THAT TODAY BUT I
WOULD ASK IF YOU WOULD
DISTRIBUTE BOTH YOUR METRICS
AND PERFORMANCE MEASURES. AND
CHEMICALLY ISSUES NOW- IN TERMS
OF THE MONEY I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S SOME. MONEY YET TO BE
DISTRICT. FINE I ASSUME THAT
THERE'S A PLAN TO DISTRIBUTE
MANY WHAT HOW MUCH MONEY IS YET
TO BE DISTRIBUTED. HE STATIONS
OF OUR OCCUR WE ARE HAD
CONVERSATIONS AROUND
DISTRIBUTING AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS DIRECTLY TO YOU OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS THIS
CONVERSATIONS ARE CONCLUDING OF
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
HAVE ACCEPTED THE ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS THROUGH COLLABORATIVE
CONVERSATION SOME OF THE CASE
IS OF SAID WE WANT YOU TO GO
AHEAD USE THE DOLLARS AND MISS
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZATIONS. SO
WE ARE PRETTY DONE WITH THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR CONTRACTS COMMIT
WE'RE WAITING FOR BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR APPROVAL ON SOME OF
THOSE COUNTY CONTRACTS SO ONCE
THOSE COME IN. AND THERE
APPROVED 90% OF THOSE DOLLARS
WILL BE OUT. SO I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE GONNA CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG THAT THERE'S ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS ARE ALLOCATED
TO. OF HARD TO KILL VETERANS IS
THAT RIGHT. BUT YOU HAVE MIDDLE
FINE ORGANIZATION TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT PROJECT.
YEAH AND CALVET WHAT ABOUT
CALVET. Q. I'M SENATOR AND WE
ARE WORKING DIRECTLY WITH CAL
THAT IS A PART OF WORKING WITH
SEVERAL OF OUR CD AGENCIES THAT
TOUCH DIFFERENT POPULATIONS-
AND THEY HAVE BEEN A GREAT
PARTNER- BECAUSE WE DID NOT
HAVE A STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
WE HAVE FOUND AN ALTERNATIVE
MEANS- TO REALLY LOOK AT HOW WE
USE THOSE DOLLARS- KEY
ENGAGEMENT THAT IT IS- BEFORE
US IS THAT COUNTY OFFICE OF
SERVICE- VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS- YOU IN THEM
INFORMATION AS ONE OF CON TO
WORK WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES IN
ADDITION WE ARE LOOKING AT
BOLSTERING. THE AREAS OF THE
STATE HOW ABOUT TRUMP SO
THROUGH THE EXISTING WORK
SUPPLEMENTING SO THAT HAVE
MAURICE TO DO EVEN MORE TARGET
THERE AS WELL THERE BUT THE
QUESTION FOR ANOTHER TIME
THERE'S ONLY ONE REAL WIDE
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OF THAT
CALVET. IT POSTED AND ALL THE
SUB ORGANIZATION AND SO. MAYBE
WE CAN TALK LATER OF WHY IT IS
THAT CALVET HAS ASSUME RUTH
THEY WORK FOR THE GOVERNOR.
SELL AT WE WILL TALK ABOUT AND
ANOTHER TIME. OF ALL. WITH TO
THE RAW OUT OF THE PROGRAM. I
AM EX THEIR VERY EVENTS
SELECTIVE AROUND THE ROLE I OF
THE PRO. IS THERE A DATABASE
ARE LIVE OF ALL THE PROGRAM
SOMEWHERE. AND BY PROGRAM SIR
CAN YOU BE A LITTLE MORE SO.
THOUGH SO EXAMPLE ON. I'M
PICKING DAY OF THE YEAR AGAIN
BUT LIKE A THE THIRD EVERY
MEMBER THE LET. I THINK IS
ENGAGED IN WELL THAT EVERY
MEMBER BUT MANY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ENGAGE IN THIS
PROJECT- IN SO WHERE WE CAN
PLUG IN TO THOSE EVENTS SO THAT
WEEK AGAIN. SOME OF THE MEMBERS
ON HERE WE TALKED ABOUT OUR
RELATIONSHIPS IN THE COMMUNITY
AND HOW YOU MIGHT. CAPITAL PAUL
CAPITALIZE UPON THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS SO IS THERE A-
EVENT SCHEDULE OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. YES THANK YOU SIR WE
ARE WORKING- TOOK AFTER
ANYTHING HIGHER IN OF IT WHERE
WE LIKE TO ASK FOR NOT ONLY
YOUR- BUT HOPE FOR COMMERCIAL.
AS WELL AS OUR LOW. OFFICIALS
I'M USING THERE'S TOO MANY TO
ASSIST US. WE ARE. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED I THINK THE
INVESTMENT OF JUST LEGISLATIVE
STAFF I'M HAPPY A DECADE MANY
STAFF ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE I'M
TO HELP COORDINATE INDIVIDUAL
BASED RECALL. HAS BEEN QUITE
HELPFUL. SO WE BOARD. DOING
THAT. BILLS RIGHT. OKAY CAN YOU
CIRCULATE THAT TO ALL OF US SO
WE KNOW WHAT EVENTS ARE PLANNED
YES OKAY GOOD THANKS OUT OF THE
FOR MY OTHER QUESTIONS THANKS
THANK YOU MAY OCCUR BERMAN.
WELL ONE THING MY COLLEAGUES
FOR ASKING A LOT THAT I WAS
GOING TO- AND A LOT OF THOSE
WERE VERY DETAIL THE NEW WANTS
AN IMPORTANT- SO WE TAKE IT A
LITTLE BIT HIGHER JUST FOR A
QUICK SECOND. IF ON MARCH
FOURTEENTH I GET THE FIRST
LETTER I'M A I'M A CONSTITUENT
IN A HARD ACCOUNT COMMUNITY AND
I GET THE FIRST LETTER- THIS
WEIRD LETTER FROM THE CENSUS
BUREAU ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH I DON'T LOVE-
TELLING ME TO GO WEBSITE AND
ENTER UNIQUE IDENTIFIER.
NOTHING ALL EXTRA EIGHTY. HOW
DO Y. FOR OUT WHERE THERE'S A
SYSTEM CENTER QUESTIONS KEY
TAKE TO GET HELP WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT SHOULD I DO AND OUR MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE AWARE THAT
ABSOLUTELY- WE ARE- DEVELOPING
A QUESTIONNAIRE ASSISTANCE
CENTER KIOSK LOCATOR SAID THAT
LOCATOR WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE IN ADDITION TO
THAT. ARE PARTNERS KNOW ABOUT
THIS LOCATOR ALSO BE ABLE TO
SHARE THAT LOCATOR WITH MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY OKAY AND OUR
MAKE SURE THAT THAT ALL OF OUR
OUR TRUSTED PARTNERS ARE
BECAUSE IT'S GREAT IF IT'S ON
THE WEBSITE BUT NOT GREAT OF
NOBODY KNOWS TO GO TO THE
WEBSITE AS TO WHAT WE YEAH YEAH
SAID TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE MAKING. DOING IN
THERE THAT. TO GO THERE CORRECT
SO APPS. AND SO ARE TO. PER THE
HAVE THEIR- WAYS OF
COMMUNICATING WHETHER IT'S
THIRTY E. NEWSLETTER OR MAYBE
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN WEBSITE OR
MAYBE THEY HAVE A FLYER. THAT
THEY CAN POST YOU KNOW
INFORMATION IF YOU NEED TO
LOCATE A QUESTIONNAIRE
ASSISTANCE CENTER GO HERE. SAYS
THEY THEY WILL BE EMPOWERED TO
SHARE THE LOCATION OF THAT.
PETER WILL BE AT OUR HOST. THAT
DIED. DURING ON ON THEIR
PERSONAL WEBSITE SO I WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE ALL OVER OUR
COMMUNITY AND THAT WE HAVE LOOK
IN THE AREAS WHERE THEY LIVE
WHERE THEY CAN GO AND RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE IN LANGUAGE BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THIS SOME FUND
KALENJIN FOR OUR COMMUNITY FOR
SURE THANK YOU AND WITH ONE OF
THE PLACES I USE GO WHEN I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR SOMETHING GOOGLE.
ARE YOU GETTING DOING. YOU KNOW
ADVERTISE IT IS IT SEEMS VERY.
BUT YEAH SURE THAT IF GOOGLE'S
LIKE ABOUT THE SENSE. ANY
QUESTION YEAH LOTS OF ANSWERS
TO. THAT ONE OF THOSE TOP LINKS.
MAYBE ON A SPONSORED LINK IS
SENDING FOR THE TO THE STATE.
RIGHT AS WELL THE- SOME
INFORMATION ARM ISN'T. THAT'S
THAT'S GOING BE UPSET THERE'S A
LOT OF ANALYTICS BEHIND. AND
SAID THAT THE IS SOME THAT MARK
YOUR ENERGY WILL WILL BE TO AND
MAKES THAT. AND THEN WE ALSO A
CHAPEL. OKAY WRITER NAY FEW ON
THE WEB. THERE ARE WEBSITE FOR
YEAH GREAT COUPLE THE QUESTIONS
NOTICED THIS MATTEO COUNTY
WHICH IS ONE OF THE COUNTY ARE
DECIDE TO DEFERRED THE EAST IN
TERMS OF THE ADDITIONAL. WHEN I
COUPLE OTHER TO THAT IS WELL
WHY. WHY OULD THEY DO. POSTED
TO. DO YOU ANY IDEA WHAT
COUNTIES BUT. NOT ONE TO GET
MONEY AND AN AND HOW MUCH MONEY
HAS ALREADY FLOWN. FLOWN FOR.
THROUGH THE COUNTY OR IN THIS
CASE THE CBO ACTUAL AN AXE.
GOTTEN ON THE- TO THE- TO THE
LOCAL NUMBER. RVTRADER THE
PHONE QUESTION I THAT VERY MUCH
OLD DOES INCOME. THAT IT
BETWEEN THE COUNTY AND THE ECB
ECHO SOME THOSE CON. REVOLVE
CAPACITY. OF THE ORGAN. AROUND
LANGUAGE ACCESS DO THEY HAVE
ENOUGH PEOPLE ALREADY ON BOARD
THEY CAN DO THE TRANSLATION
THAT CAN DO THAT- IN LÏNG
WHICH OUTRAGE- SO IT WASN'T
FORCED CONVERSATION HE WAS
STOPPED BY A COLLABORATIVE
CONVERSATION THAT OCCURRED- AND
I THINK THOSE WERE LOW. TO SAY
THAT ARE MADE GOTCHA AND A LOT
OF THEM GOT ME. TO THE GROUND
TO THE TO THE SEAT IS ONLY
FOUNDER IS STILL CALL. COUNTY
THERE ARE WITH THE IS A NOT A
HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED. NO IT'S- A
HIGH. THEIR OWN RELATIONSHIPS
CONTRACTS A- AND THAT THE
INVOICE. ARE BEING. WE HAVEN'T.
OF ANY LOW. COP ACTOR THAT ARE
ISSUE AT THIS TIME WE ARE ALL
IS HAVE OUR. HERE'S A.
TECHNOLOGICAL PRODUCT- YOU KNOW
WE CAN CAN GO WRONG- WHAT WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT-
DO WHAT WE MEETINGS OR DOING TO
MAKE SURE THIS SORT IS REALLY
KIND OF PRESSURE TEST TESTED IN
AND READY FOR SOME TIME AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN SO MANY PEOPLE
START INPUTTING INFORMATION CAN
UPLOADING INFORMATION INTO IT-
SO COUPLE THINGS AND THERE WE
HAVE A DEDICATED STAFF THAT'S
RIGHT SORT. AS WELL AS PDI SAN
TI WHICH IS ANOTHER ONE OF OUR
TOOL AND WE HAVE REGULAR
COMMUNICATION AND WEBER OURS
WITH OLIVER USERS DOES. AT THAT
CON BEING MY BIRD YOU KNOW THAT.
THERE IS CAN. RESEARCH AT A
CERTAIN UPGRADE SIR TECH LIST
AROUND SOME OF THE RIVER FONG.
OF OUR TOOL SO WE FEEL
CONFIDENT WE'VE WERE PROVIDING
THAT PURPOSE LEVEL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND THAT WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES IN PLACE IN ORDER
TO MEET ANY CHALLENGE IS RIGHT
GREAT JUST THE LONG AS WERE.
ANTICIPATED ALL THE THINGS THAT
COULD GO. YEAH AND DOESN'T LIKE
IT TODAY WE ACTUALLY A BI PART
CAN. AND THEN SO I WANT TO ASK
A ON BEHALF OF A COLLEAGUE BE.
OUR OUR FELLOW COMMITTEE
SOMEONE MEMBER FLOOR HIS IS ONE
REFLECTS OF THE ROLE IN THE AND
LINGUISTIC CHIU. OF THE SENSE
AND THERE ARE A OF ROLE OF A
SUMMER FORCE THIS THAT DON'T
EVER LIVE HIGH SPEED INTERNET
ACCESS SO WHAT RADIO AND TV
RESOURCE HAVE BEEN CAN. FOR
THESE PARTS OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THEN ALL OF ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. I WOULD
DEFER TO. BE ON THE- RADIO AND-
OTHER AVENUES OKAY. MARKET YOU
HAVE HAD UP THEY'LL BE A ABOUT
THE IN THEN THE ME JUST SEE.
WELL AND DOS YOU HAVE THIS BY
TO BOTH COUNTY AND SEE WORKING
CAN. MADE THE LIST OF S. COUNTY
MOST AT RISK OF ANOTHER. WILL
BE HAPPY ON THE- IN THOSE
COUNTIES IN THE NEXT THE OVER
THE NEXT THIRTY DAYS AND I
GUESS SIMILARLY IN SOME OF OUR
OTHER MORE RURAL. COUNTIES SO
I'M IN. AT SEA. ARE AROUND THE
SAME. SIR DOING THAT TO. HIGH
HI IN OR OUT. WITH OUR CAN. IS
IT'S NOT AN EASY CA. TO HAVE
BECAUSE ONE. RUNNING AGAIN AT.
BELIEVES BEHAVIORS OF OUR
COMMUNITY- THEY'D THEY MAY NOT
SEE THE VALUE OF THE SENSES SO
WE MAY HAVE TO COME BACK OR IN.
ANOTHER TIME. I'M IN IT. THAT
ROUTE. AROUND I'M OUTRIGHT EACH
STRATEGY THAT WE HAVE. WE'RE
WILL BE ABLE TO DO THE DOOR
KNOCKING BUT THAT ALSO. WHEN
THEY DROP OFF THEIR CHILDREN AT
SCHOOL. THEY'LL SEE THE PO. OR
MAYBE THE SCHOOL. A DISTANCE
THAT. OF OR THE C. L. ON BOARD
AS A DRIVE DOWN THE ROAD OR ARE
AT THEIR- IN TRAFFIC FOR HOUR
SO THE HERE THE RAID.
COMMERCIALS SO. IT'S THAT THAT
WRAP AROUND. THE HAS WHITE OUT.
WHICH I'M SURE. WEST TO THOSE
GONNA MORE ALSO IS AT SOMETHING
THAT THEY ALL ARE EQUIPPED
DANCE. WHERE IT. TO ANSWER IT
BUT WE'VE LIKE WORKING MAY BE
ABLE TO YOU A BETTER JOB I
WOULD. OKAY THANK YOU MUCH ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO I
JUST KNOWLEDGE AND SOME ADDED
TO IN AT THE BEFORE BUT I LIKE
HE WAS THERE ARE COVER L. BOXES
AS OPPOSED TO ADDRESSES. SO DO
WE HAVE A SOLUTION FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE USING-
UTILIZING PO BOXES. AT THE
OUTRAGE STRATEGY- AGAIN IS
GOING OUT JUST FINDING OUT
WHERE OR COMMUNITIES LIVE-
DOING THAT CAMPUS SEEING- THE
PHONE BANKING ALSO SELL MANY OF
US HAVE CELLPHONES THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE PHONE CALLS-
FOR MANY OF OUR RULE
COMMUNITIES IS ALSO MEETING
THEM WHERE THEY WORK. SURVEYS
AT THE FARM COMMUNITY OUT.
HOLDS UP DURING LUNCH TIME OR
YOU KNOW AFTER THE HOUR IN
BEING IT SHARE THEM. ABOUT THIS
AND SHERRY STORY ABOUT. THE
CENSUS ADDERS AND OF FILLING
OUT THE SENATE THIS. COME NEXT
IN YEARS WILL RECEIVE A SAN. IN
FOR IN THE PO OR NO. HE WILL BE
IN I STATES CENSUS SAID RAP. IN
FOR ME. I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
WILL NOT DIRECTLY TO THE PO
OFFICE. IT WILL THEY'LL BE
DROPPED OFF FORM AT ACTUAL FOR
HOUSEHOLD LOOK THERE IS AN MATH
IT UP ANYMORE SHIN THOSE HOUSE
OF A FEW ABOUT OKAY AND MORE
FOR ME. THAT WOULD BE GREAT
RISK THAT BECAUSE THANK YOU.
THANK A YES A CENTER COMMA A-
I'M SORRY I'M- MISSED WHAT YOU
SAY EVEN THOUGH I WAS. WHAT WAS
THE ANSWER TO THE- OR- REACHING
OUT TO VETERANS AND ACTIVE MY
WHO WERE HERE WE ARE ENGAGE
DIRECTLY WITH AND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF THAT AFFAIRS BUT
ABSENT A STEEP WE'RE GONNA MY
ARE OR IF COMMUNITY BETTER
ORGANIZATION MODELING AFTER
THAT BALANCE OF OUR COUNTRY WE
HAVE ON TAKEN ALTERNATE
APPROACH FOR REACHING A
COMMUNITIES THE COMMUNITY. THE
CALIFORNIA THAT WE AWARE HAVE A
HIGH POPULATION. AND YOU KNOW I
THINK I'M- ABOUT THE BETWEEN.
COM AND GAVE. AND THE ACTUAL
FOR OF ACTIVE. BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S REALLY FLEW. AND YET
APRIL FOR DISPATCH APPROACHING
AND IN MY MIND LISTENING TO YOU
ARE. I'M THINKING ABOUT THE
DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE EXPANDED
AND THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT OF
THAT AND IT SEEMS REALLY- PAY.
AND SO. IF THERE IS A WAY TO.
HELP MY MIND FIND SOME CLARITY
WITH MILESTONES THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE AND REACHED IF WE ARE
MAKING THE TIME LINES THAT WE
HAVE SET- THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
BECAUSE- I JUST LET MY MIND
MONEY REALLY. ACROSS THE STATE
AND THEN IT'S LIKE WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY INFORMATION BUT
WE'RE TALKING TO LOTS OF PEOPLE
AND SO MAYBE I'M JUST HEARING
THE THING WRONG THAT YOU'RE
SAYING BUT CAN YOU TELL ME THAT
I'M HEARING YOU WRONG. SO THE
IMPLEMENTATION. PLANS WHICH
WERE RECENTLY SUBMITTED TO US
OF THOSE CONTAIN THOUSANDS OF
LINES OF ACTIVITIES. THERE'S
ACTIVITIES ARE. WHAT WE ARE
INVESTING IN. SO WE ARE
INVESTING IN- INDIVIDUALS RUBY
AT VENTS INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO WILL BE
CONDUCTING A PRESENTATION.
INDIVIDUALS AND THEY CAN BE
THEY'LL BE DOING THE PHONE
BANKING AND THE CANVASSING. SO
THE CONVERSE IT AND- I
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM BECAUSE CONVERSATIONS SEEM
REALLY LIKE AND WHAT DO YOU SAY
IN. BUT COM. REALLY IS WHAT
NEED TO HAPPEN IN THESE HAVE
BEEN IN MULTIPLE WAYS BECAUSE
WE ARE. WE ARE WORKING KIM.
SAID STATE WHAT THIS DOES A
THREE. TO WE TO. KEEP ON WHAT.
THE CENSUS AS THE FIRST COVER.
THE VERB TENSE AND SO I'M JUST
WONDER IF HAVE PASSED HIM YOU
RIGHT YES YES ABSOLUTELY SO
THESE CONVERSATIONS BEEN GO ON
SINCE LATE LAST YEAR. SEPT
OCTOBER WE HAD A- PLAN WORKSHOP
IN THIS. EVEN DURING THE SIMPLE
PLAN WORKS WE ARE HAD OUR
COMMUNITY TRUST A PARTNERS ARE
READ IN THE FEEL HAVING
CONVERSE AND UP A LOT IN IN RE
REACHING OUT AND BUILD A THAT
IN FOR. IN THE COMMUNITIES SO
IT HAS IT IT IS OUR IT BEHALF
IT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN AND IT
WILL ONLY HAVE TO CONTINUE
THROUGHOUT THE RESPONSE. SPELL
YEAH MY OTHER COLLEAGUES OKAY
GET THAT DATA FROM. ABSOLUTELY
ONE QUICK UP AND WE GET THOSE
IN PLANS YOU MENTIONED YOU
RECENTLY BECAUSE IT BE GREAT
FOR US BE ABLE TO TAKE A AT
THOSE I WAS GOING ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU M. IF. COUPLE
QUESTIONS WELL APPRECIATE ALL
QUESTION MY COLLEAGUE. TO SO
CERTAINLY THE YOU'VE HEARD A
THING ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
SELECT I THINK GAME MORE
CERTAINTY WHAT DONE UP TO DATE
I THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING.
TO THE BUT WE ALSO KNOW THE
PREP WORK LEE UP SO WHAT SO
BASICALLY IT'LL FOR TRADE IS GO
DAY AND GET THEIR THERE IN.
RIGHT ACT FRANKLY PRIVATE ABOUT
WEEK AFTER OUR PRIMARY ELECTION
AND I DO WAY KNOWLEDGE AND ON
SURE WE'LL HAVE DISCUSS MERGER
WELL TIE ME A MESSAGE. IN AND
SO FORTH AS WELL SO HOW HOW TO
DO THAT. THIS GO DAY. WELL HAVE
IS PEOPLE STAR FILLING OUT KEY
TALKING THE PROCESS BY WHICH
OKAY SO HOW IS THAT PEOPLE STE
FILLING OUT THEIR SENSE. YOUR
GET I BELIEVE DATA AND YOU
SENSE OF BOROUGH LIKE WELL I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT FILLED IT OUT
BUT BASS WHICH SENSES TRACKS IN
SO FORTH SO YOU TALKED ABOUT
YOU MADE YOU PRESS TO CAN PLANS
WILL BE WE I THINK WE ARE ALL
FAMILIAR GEO OTHER THIS IS LIKE
A SEVERAL MY THE TEAM HELLO
WITH MAIL IN BALLOTS AGO.
SIMILAR SO WHAT FORCES YOU SEE.
SEC THAT'S IS ROLE OUT DURING A
ROLL AND THEN YEAH FOR NOT
BEING MAY JUNE. S. THAT I
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THING SO
WHAT ARE THE PLANS FOR IT FOR
THAT CONTINGENCY PLANS FOR
DRESSING- THE THESE THINGS THAT
PROBABLY NOT JUST CONTINGENCY
WE SHOULD EXPECT IT RIGHT. NOW
INDEED I THINK- WHAT TO EXPECT
EXACTLY IS ON THE PART YET TO
BE SEEN- SO YES DOCTOR PAN
THANK YOU- FOR. NOTING AND WE
WILL GET. IN FOR ME THAT COMES
DOWN FROM THE US CENSUS BUREAU-
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
DISTINCTIONS TO MAKE- IS THAT
BECAUSE IT IS THE FIRST AND
THAT OFFER SPOTS WILL BE
CONDUCTED ONLINE. WE WILL HAVE.
OUT HERE SAID ON BECAUSE IN
TWENTY TEN THE RESPONSE ATES
THAT WE WILL HAVE WILL BE
RELATIVE TO MAIL PARTICIPATION
RATE SO WE KNOW. YOU'RE AROND
HAVING TO FEEL SOMETHING OUT
PHYSICALLY AND SUBMITTING AT
RELATIVE TO BEING ABLE TO GO ON
YOUR PHONE OR OTHER DEVICE WILL
BE DIFFERENT IT IS SOMETHING.
AND WE ARE MINDFUL OF- BUT FEEL
CONFIDENT AS A RELATIVE DATA
POINT- IN LOOKING AT HOW EACH.
TRACK IS. FUNDING THAT WE BE
ABLE TO FIVE ON SOME OF OUR-
DECISION MAKING AND REALLY. IN
WORKING WITH THOSE CONTRACTED
PARTNERS- THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS AND OTHER
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE OUT
REACH TEAM IS HAVING DIRECTLY
WITH THOSE. DOORS THE HAVE
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
VIDEOS ARE. ON NOT REALLY ABLE
TO MOVE AND WHAT ACTIVITIES CAN
BE FLEXIBLE. SO IN A SCENARIO
PERHAPS WE HAVE TWO TRACKS NEXT
TO EACH OTHER FOR THE SAKE OF
EXAMPLE. ONE IS UNDER BRING ONE
BECAUSE- FORM. WE TAKE THOSE
OTHER. AND SLIDE THEM. RIGHT
AND TRY TO CONCENTRATE ON THOSE
THAT HAVE EVER. YET AS WELL AS-
IN AREAS WHERE. WE MADE ENOUGH
LOW RESPONSE RATE INTO TEN
MAYBE. I'M JUST. I'M HAPPY HELP
RESOLVE STRUCK. FURTHER AND A
LITTLE BIT FOR ETHNOLOGY ING
YOU KNOW TEN RIGHT. AREAS MIGHT
NOT HAVE BEEN DESIRABLE AND THE
TERMS OF FINANCIAL. RESOURCES
NOW WITH ABOUT. OR GET OUT BUT
PORTION OF FOR RESOURCE DO YOU
NEED FOR BASE THESE TYPE OF ARE
ARE DO YOU EXPECT THEM OF ITS
RATE BUILT IN AND EXPECTATIONS
WITH EXISTING CONTRACT TO A DO
YOU. DO YOU DESERVE OF
RESOURCES THAT YEAR I WOULD SAY
HOLDING YEAH BUT YEAH BASICALLY
INTO BASICALLY THE TYPES OF ACT
IS TO PROVIDE TARGET. YES FOR
COMING IT IS THAT THAT AS THE
CENSUS IS ROLLING ON. THIRTY
TWO DIFFERENT POTS OF
CONTINGENCY PLANS SO THE
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION- I WALK
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE PRIORITY
AREAS AND ONE OF THEM WAS THAT
CAN CHEN C. FUNDS SO MAKING
SURE THAT PARTNER MAKING NUYS
THAT IT'S NOT A- SCENARIO BUT
IS. ONE SCENARIO WHEN YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO REINVEST SO
WHETHER THAT'S PRINTING MORE IN
LANGUAGE X. THAT ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL JUST RECOGNIZE ZING N.
EMPHASIZING THAT IT WILL HAPPEN
TO MAKE SURE YOU SENT US AT THE
BOTTOM IN THE PROGRAM. THE
MONEY ON THIS SIDE WE ALSO HAVE
OUR OWN CONTINGENCY FUNDING
THAT THAT WE WILL HAVE
AVAILABLE AND AGAIN I CAN GO
THROUGH. YOU CAN GO TO PRINT
CHANGE IT MAY NEED TO GO
THROUGH. ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION EVERYWHERE WE'RE
ONLY. ABOUT HOW MUCH DO YOU DO
YOU ARE YOU. SAYING THAT
ROUGHLY. IT BUDGET AFFECT
WEALTHIEST A LOOK IT UP MAYBE
CAN GET BACK TO ME ON THAT.
LEDGE REPORT IN TERMS OF THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT WE SET ASIDE
FOR CONTINGENCY BUDGET. OKAY
BUT WILL. OKAY AND THEN THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS. AGAIN
SOARED. FISHY TO TOOL WE
DEVELOP THAT- I THINK YOU HEARD
ABOUT THE NEED FOR IT TO BE
ROBUST AND SO FORTH- BUT ONE
THE OTHER THING- THAT HURT A
LITTLE FEEDBACK ON ANY
APPRECIATE THAT WE WANNA BE
DATA DRIVEN. DATE ALSO TO BE
COLLECTED AND TAKES TIMES AND
SOURCES. SO HAVE YOU BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH COMMITTEE
PARTNERS ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
DATA ACTUALLY THE- DOES THE DAY
WE LIKE TO HAVE THERE'S THE IT
REALLY NEED. AND SOMETIMES THE
LIKE THAT HAVE MEANS A LOT OF
EXTRA WORK SO- THAT DIFFERENT
CONVERSATIONS OUT. THE RESPOND
BURDEN. LOADING THING TO. WHEN
WE WHAT KIND OF INFORMATION FOR
FROM SOME. LIKE IT'S ALMOST.
PEOPLE ENORMOUS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A POLITICAL LOT OF DAY AND-
THAT TAKES A BUDGET AND THEY'RE
ALMOST I DON'T TOUCH THE THING
THIS IS GOING ME ALL THESE
QUESTIONS AND I HAVE TIME TO
ACTUALLY ANSWER ALL THESE
QUESTIONS RIGHT. SO CAN YOU
JUST ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. SO ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION PLANS WE
TOOK. PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING THAT
WAS SUBMITTED TO US AND WE'RE
DOING THE CLEANUP. SO THAT.
THERE IS A LOT OF EFFORT
THEY'RE GOING ON. JUST ONE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE TEAM IS
WORKING IS SUPER FAST ON THAT
AND- AS- ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN UPLOADS. AND THEN ON THE
REPORTING SIDE. FOR OUR
ACTIVITIES SAID THE PARTNERS
ONCE THEY COMPLETE THE ACTIVITY
THEY GO. IN AND THEY TELL. US
THERE'S PROBABLY ABOUT FIVE.
DIFFERENT FIELDS THAT ARE MY-
CATS. SO THAT INCLUDES A NUMBER
OF IMPRESSIONS OF THE
PERCENTAGE OF EACH. POPULATION
THAT YOU READ. STORE SOME.
SENSE OF IT- AND EVERYTHING IS.
PRETTY MUCH. OPTIONAL SO WE
DID. GO TO. EXERCISE MINIMAL.
EFFORT TO GET. AGAIN I SENT TO.
GREAT CELLS ALL RIGHT WELL I
THINK YOU MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENT
YES YES SENATE KALLIO I
APOLOGIZE I AM I HAVE SOME NO
BEEN I REALIZED THERE THEIR
QUESTIONS CURRY BUT BEFORE WE
GET TO THE TO THOSE QUESTIONS
WE JUST HAD A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO. THERE ARE OVER IT
OF THAT SO. I'M THEIR COME NEXT
WHAT THEM SOME. AND THEN IF
WANTED TO UP I DO COULD YOU
TELL ME WHO. WHO HAS OVERSIGHT
AND OF THEIR CONTRACT. OF
COURSE- ARE A DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR COMMUNICATIONS IS HERE AS
WELL HER NAME IS MARTHA
DOMINGUEZ THAT IF THE EXECUTIVE
TEAM MEMBER- THAT IS THE
CONTRACT MANAGER FOR MERCURY.
ON THAT SIDE OF IT YEAH- OUR
ENTIRE TEAM FAIR AND I ARE
ALSO. I'M HERE FOR OVERSIGHT A
MONTH THAT'S HELPFUL. AS AS WE
START TO LOOK AT BUT- THE KIND
OF THE OUTRAGE THAT WE'RE
DOING- MY THINK WE ALL HAVE
IDEAS ABOUT. WHAT WOULD BE
GOOD. TO GET OUT THERE. AND
FRANKLY HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT OF.
LEARN BECAUSE I HAVEN'T SEEN A
LOT OF MEDIA OUT REACH IN IN MY
REGION AS I TRAVEL AROUND AND I
HAVEN'T. SEEN A LOT OF ACTIVITY
IN SOME OF THE COMMUNITIES AND
SOME A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE CAN WE KNOW WHO
TO CALL HOW TO. INVOLVE THEM
WHEN I THINK ALL OF US WANT TO
BE INVOLVED IN IN THAT OUT
REACH SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN
HAVE COMMUNICATION THE BETTER I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE SELF.
THE APPRECIATE THAT. WELL ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE I AM AND I KNOW
THAT- WERE ALSO WORKING
TOGETHER TO THINKING ABOUT THE
LUNCH EVENTS AND CERTAINLY.
IT'S OF POINTED OUT THAT OUR
DISTRICT. OFFICES HAVE.
RELATIONSHIPS AND I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN PARTNERING ON A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT THINGS BUT- TERMS OF
THE ACTUAL WATCH. THIS OF
COURSE- WE ARE YOU KNO WE WANT
TO BE. A STRONG PARTNERS AND
HELPING TO SHOW SUCCESSFUL
SENSE OF STYLE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I THINK YOU HAVE A
LIST OF. THINGS THAT WE WANT
YOU TO FOLLOW UP WITH
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS AND THE
OTHER AT THAT OUR DATA. DEL
MEDICS AND WORDS OF YOU CAN GET
THAT OUR STAFF. GREAT THREAT. I
KNOW YOU. AROUND HERE. RELATED
QUESTIONS OKAY SO NEXT STEP IS
WE HAVE ON STATE OUT REGION
PUBLIC RELATIONS CAMPAIGN
UPDATE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CALIFORNIA CENSUS COMMUNICATION
PLAN WE HAVE MARKED REPUBLIC
AFFAIRS WITH CAROLINE BECKER
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT PAULETTE
BROWN HINES WE SPECIALIST AND
STACY LATELY GAVE ME A
SPECIALIST JUST CUTTING PLEASE
COME UP. SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT-
YOU CAN COME UP TO THE TABLE
HERE A FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS I
KNOW THE LAST TIME WE HAD YOU
I'M HERE YES GUIDE YOU
CONTRACTED A LOT OF QUESTIONS
THAT WE'RE AND WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON IT THE THAT THAT US.
YOUR EAT BEING ANSWER ALL THIS
SINCE TODAY. AS WE ARE ONLY A
MONTH FROM PEOPLE GETTING
NOTICE. SO WELCOME AND I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD
THANK YOU. YEAH. OKAY SO- YOU
CAN NOT MADE IT WHICH A REVERSE
FISCALLY OFF AND START. WELCOME
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIRS AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US TODAY.
OKAY SHARE HERE. BY LIKE I SAID
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US TODAY
TEARS A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- WERE YOU GOING TO
GIVE YOU GUYS AN UPDATE ON ALL
OF THE WORK WE'VE BEEN DOING IN
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH THE
CENSUS OFFICE TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS THAT WE ALL SHARE. IN
PARTICULAR. THE COUNT
CALIFORNIANS. UP HIGHLIGHTING A
POINT THAT WAS MADE IN THE
EARLIER PANEL. OUR CAMPAIGN TO
HAS BEEN DRIVEN- BY. DATA AS
WELL AS RESEARCH AND THAT
INCLUDES RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE
BEFORE WE WERE PARTNERS OF THE
STATE. AS WELL AS RESEARCH
THAT'S UNDER WAY AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE UNDER WAY
THROUGHOUT THE CAMPAIGN SO THAT
WE CAN ADJUST AND- PIVOT.
NECESSARY BUT IT'S ALSO
COMMUNITY AT. ARMS REALLY HERE
TO LIFT UP THE WORK. THAT'S
BEING. FOUND IN THE- EIGHTIES.
WELL AS- I. YOUR INSIGHT. AND
APPLY THEM TO OUR- MEDIA.
COMMUNICATIONS STRATEGY AS AS
WE GO. THAT CLEAN AB ELEMENT
FROM THE BEGINNING OF AN IN.
BRAND AND APPLYING THAT TO
ACROSS CREATIVE PLATFORMS THAT
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF CREATIVE-
BOTH THAT WE'VE- DEVELOPED AND
CONTINUING TO DEVELOP ACROSS.
MEDIA PLATFORMS ALL OF IT
KEEPING COMMUNITIES AND THE
VARIOUS CULTURES THAT ARE I
CAMPAIGN IS AIMING TO REACH
REALLY REALLY CENTRAL TO THAT
CREATIVE AND I'LL SHOW YOU SOME
OF THAT AND IN THE COMING
SLIDES. I AND THEN IT'S PART OF
MY JOB IN OUR TEAM'S JOB TO
ENSURE THAT WERE BEING
STRATEGIC ACROSS PLATFORMS
WHETHER IT'S PAID MEDIA SOCIAL
MEDIA EARNED MEDIA. THAT WERE
REALLY ECHOING OURSELVES AND
THE SAME MESSAGES. REINFORCE
CASE TO SEND. HAVE FOUND MODE.
IN ANOTHER. ONE HUNDRED AND
BETTER THERE ARE APT TO PUT. I
AND- PARTICULAR FEET WE'RE
LIFTING UP ON WHAT CHANNEL WE-
WERE. NOT ON. REST OF THIS SO
THAT PEOPLE ARE ARE TO AND- THE
STATURE. AND THE THEMES THAT
WERE THAT WERE DEPLOYING
THROUGHOUT THIS CAMPAIGN. SO
JUST GET SHOWING YOU SOME
SAMPLING OF OUR CREATIVE- WHICH
LIKE I SAID IS REALLY ROOTED IN
A CULTURAL CONGRUENT OUR
STRATEGY. YOU HAVE SOME OF YOUR
SOME OF OUR OUR DIGITAL
ADVERTISEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IN THE MARKET PLACE FOR A WHILE
THOSE ARE TYPICALLY THE EASIEST
FASTEST TO DEPLOY AND CAN BE
REALLY STRATEGIC THAT AND ON
THE RIGHT HAND SIDE YOU SEE. A
VERY SIMILAR LOOK AND FEEL TO
ONE OF OUR PRINT ADVERTISEMENTS
THEIR- I SHOULD MENTION THAT
OUR ADVERTISING I. COMES FROM
IS ROOTED ALSO IN THE LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN SO WE HAVE DEPLOYED
ADVERTISING ACROSS THE THIRTEEN
LANGUAGES THAT ARE HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE PLAN I WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT AND CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
WHICH LANGUAGES ARE RESONATING
WITH WHICH COMMUNITIES BOTH
THROUGH OUR MEDIA AS WELL AS
THROUGH OUR WEBSITE. YOU CAN
SEE THAT WE HAVE DEPLOYED A
RANGE OF MESSAGES I THAT THAT
TARGET VERY SPECIFIC AGE TO
SEIZE IN SOME CASES IT'S ABOUT
A VERY SPECIFIC AUDIENCE
ANOTHER CASES IT'S JUST ABOUT
KEEPING THAT GENERAL EDUCATION
MESSAGE. ON THE RIGHT IS AN AD
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH
A STATE AGENCY PARTNER OVER AT
FIRST FIVE TO CO BRAND- AND
THAT'S A THEME THAT YOU'LL HEAR
THROUGHOUT TODAY IS HOW WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO COLLABORATE WITH
PARTNERS. TO WORK TOGETHER AND
ENHANCE THE CAMPAIGN LIKE I
SAID BOTH FROM THE GROUND AND
THE AIR. SIMILARLY WE ARE-
DEPLOYING CULTURALLY CONGRUENT
IMAGES AND MESSAGES ALL ACROSS
OUR SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNELS. WE
HAVE BUILT A STEADY FOLLOWING
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
LAUNCHING TWITTER FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM. THE ILLUSTRATED
SUGGEST THAT ILLUSTRATE A
GRAPHIC AT THE TOP IS SOMETHING
WE LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT BECAUSE WE
HAVE- HEARD IN NUMBER OF OUR
FOLKS. THAT SOMETIME IN SOME
CASES THESE IT STRAIGHT IT OF
GRAPHICS ARE REALLY REALLY REST
EATING WITH COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
IT I THINK GENERALLY KIND OF
FUN BUT THEY ALSO SAY FEET. IN
THEM WITHOUT BEING VERY
SPECIFIC PARTICULAR PC SO I.
ILLUSTRATIONS ALLOW SOME OF OUR
AUDIENCE TO SEE THEMSELVES IN
IT WHETHER IT WHETHER IT'S
SOMEBODY WHO LOOKS LIKE THEM OR
NOT. SIMILAR TO THE BOTTOM HERE
WERE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
PARTICULAR DAYS ON THE CALENDAR
WHEN IT MAKES SENSE- AND WHEN
THERE ARE PARTICULAR DAYS THAT
ARE RELEVANT TO OUR AGE TO SEE
COMMUNITIES. THE LEFT SIDE
FUTURE SEMESTERS BETTER AGAIN
MORE JUST CONTINUING THAT
DRUMBEAT OF EDUCATION SO THAT
PEOPLE WE ARE TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT THEY NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
THE TENSEST BEFORE IT'S UNDER
WAY. I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY I
GUESS THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN JUST
A FEW WEEKS AGO IN JANUARY TWO
FEATURE WITH A DIGITAL
BILLBOARD THIS IS ACTUALLY. A
TRUCK IN THE MLK THEM DAY
PARADE IN. LESS BEECHING'S
FEATURING SOME OF OUR OUR
CAMPAIGN SO JUST I DIDN'T GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE CAMPAIGN
DEPLOYED. WHAT I LIKE TO CALL
IN REAL LIFE. BUT THIS WAS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE WORKING
COORDINATION WITH CALIFORNIA
CALLS IN MY BLACK COUNCIL
REALLY. A CO BRANDED THIS
DIGITAL. MOVING BOARD IF WELL
AS PART OF THAT THAT REALLY-
INCREDIBLE PARADE. OKAY THIS IS
WHERE THE TECHNICAL ASPECT
COMES IN ALT TAB RIGHT SO WE
ALSO HAVE KING IN CLOSE JACKSON
WITH OUR MEDIA PARTNERS. PLAY
FOR YOU THAT LITTLE CLASS OF
OUR AND AT A RECENT SEGMENT
THAT WE TAPED WITH UNIVISION
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY START AIR
THIS WEEK AS PART OF. AMERICA
AND LET'S SEE ALL I GET THIS
RIGHT DICE. SINCE YEAH. WHEN WE
LET HIM BUT AS AN ADULT ON
DEVELOPERS ARE NOT GETTING MOST
IN A THOUSAND GO TO CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT TO MAKE THIS ALL
IT'S ALL ME THAT THIRTY WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT IN THIS IN
SOME OF THE COMBINED YOU CAN IF
THE. THE LA IS FULLY CAPABLE OF.
IDENTICAL ONE OF. ONE OF THE-
ME THAT SENSE OF. THING NOT A-
ONE IS THAT THE LATEST THAT I
LIVE BUT I BELIEVE. YEAH I
SCHOOL WHEN HE THAT. IT SAYS
THAT OUR MEDIA PARTNERS HAVE
PUT TOGETHER AND YOU'LL HEAR
MORE ABOUT THAT COMING UP IN
OUR PAID MEDIA SECTION BUT WE
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
PARTICULAR ONE BECAUSE IT IS.
QUITE RECENT AND WILL BE
AIRING- AS EARLY AS THIS WEEK
WERE ALSO WORKING WITH THE
STYLE WITH THE CENSUS OFFICE
COMMUNICATIONS ON. THE VETERAN
STRATEGY YOU GUYS HAVE ASKED A
FEW TIMES ABOUT. AND I THIS IS
A LITTLE BIT OF A TEASER AND
I'LL PLAY THAT YOU KNOW AS
WELL. ARE YOU IT'S QUITE ROB.
BUT THIS IS- AN- EXAMPLE OF
CREATIVE THAT WE ARE. WORKING
TO COLLABORATE ON A LIFT UP AS
PART OF OUR- MEDIA. G. SPACE.
HI I'M RUN THANK YOU ON A
SUBMARINE SONAR TECHNICIAN
VETERAN RETIRED NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR MY SERVICE COUNTED DAN MY
SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY CAST
NOW IN APRIL WHEN I TAKE THE
CENSUS I'M AN ACCOUNT AND THEN
FOR THE NEXT TEN. SO SOME OF
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY VERY VERY
SPECIFIC TO OUR VETERAN- H. T.
C. COMMUNITY AND THAT'S- FULL
THE FOLDING INTO OUR SPECIFIC
MESSAGING WHICH HAS NEW ONES AS
FOR ANY GIVEN H. T. C. AS WELL
AS OUR MORE BROUGHT JAMES LOOKS
TO DRIVE HOME THOSE EDUCATIONAL
POINTS THAT I MENTIONED AS WELL
AS THE MOTIVATIONAL ASPECTS
ABOUT WIVES CONSISTS REALLY NOT
TO NOT ONLY AND CALIFORNIA BUT
INSTEAD IS VERY. HEALTH CASE
ELEVEN MIL LANGUAGES SO I WOULD
I WOULD- SHARE THAT ARE THAT
ARE- TARGETING IS HIGHLY
SURGICAL AND STRATEGIC YOU
HEARD ABOUT THE HARDEST TO
COUNT INDEX WE'VE BEEN WORKING
DEEP IN THAT DATA AND TO THE
THAT WE CAN USE YES.
SPECIFICALLY TARGET ELEVEN
MILLION VERY SPECIFIC
CALIFORNIANS YOU KNOW THAT IS
WANTED FOR IT AS I BELIEVE
STONE YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
CALIFORNIANS BUT THAT MEANS
THAT'S THREE IN FOR THAT WE'RE
NOT WE'RE SORT PLEADING TO THE
GIRLS HAPPENS OR- THEY'LL PICK
UP FROM OUR CAMPAIGN BECAUSE
THEY- ANYWAY. WE ARE WE ARE
OKAY SOLELY ON REACHING DEAL
MILLION AND SHE REACHED THAT IS
THAT INDEX THE HIGHEST ON THE
HARDEST ACCOUNTS. ALSO EARLIER-
ABOUT THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COLLABORATION AND MERCURY IS
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH NEW
NASA WHO WE REALLY SEE A
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS IN THE
NATIVE AMERICAN MEDIA SPACE I
KNOW THEY CAME UP ON THE PANEL
EARLIER- AS A AS A CONTRACTOR
OF THE STATE AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PLUG IT IN. OUR STATE
BY LOGO AND BUSTED MY- CAN
COMMUNITY WITH INSIGHTS FROM
THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
AND THIS IS JUST THE VERY FIRST
SAMPLE OF ART THAT WE WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO AS A RESULT OF OUR
COLLABORATION. USING ARE PAID
MEDIA ALERT PLANS. UP LIFT THE
CREATIVE REALLY REALLY BEING
DRIVEN BY THOSE COMMUNITY. PART
WITH SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT IN
ANY GIVEN SPACE. I'M GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE STACY
LOOK AT TAKE A DEEPER DIVE INTO
THE PAID MEDIA ASPECT. THANKS
CAROLYN MESSAGING AS A CREDIT.
OF OUR CAMPAIGN AND IT WILL
MAKE ARM YEAH MORE EFFECTIVE
AND- SO THANK YOU FOR SETTING
THAT UP FOR US. I AM I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE WANT
TO START OFF WITH IS IN OUR
LAST. AND TIME WE WERE HERE WE
TALKED ABOUT BEING NIMBLE. WITH
THE SENATE VERY STRATEGIC
APPROACH AND PLAN AND THE WAY
THAT WE WERE GOING TO BE
EXECUTING I'M OUR CAMPAIGN WITH
A VERY. WINDY WELL THAT WE HAD
TO PUT TOGETHER THE ROLLOUT BY.
THREE I'M ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT- DEMONSTRATED. PAUL
AS HERE. DOESN'T PARA THAT NEED
FOR I'D JOBBING A NUMERATORS-
AT PEOPLE TAKE A PLOT IS JOBS-
SO WE I AM WITH CAROLINE'S
LEADERSHIP. AND THE CREATIVE
TEAM AND WORKING WITH THE
SERVICES OFFICE. DEVELOPED ADDS
VERY QUICKLY THANK BY CAN STATE.
IN TURN ON. I'M UP I AS PER OF
AN HOUR COMPONENT OF OUR
DIGITAL CAMPAIGN I'M TO BE
RESPONSIVE AND TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING
SURE WE HAVE PEOPLE HERE TAKE
COUNT AND GO OUT AND INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE WE GET A
FULL COUNT. THIS ISN'T AND ALL
OF. AMBLE AND IN OUR CAMPAIGN
TURN OFF WITH SOME LIKE A LIGHT
AB AS WE START TO GET THE
DETAILS VERY LIKE IT CAMPAIGN.
ONE OF THE I WANT TO I AM.
INSIDE WRAPPED UP. I AM ALSO
VERY CONSCIOUS OF. YES IT'S
TIME HERE I KNOW WE- QUESTION
FOR USE BY YOUR SENSE OF HOW
MUCH LOVE YOU YOU. HIT YOUR TEN
MINUTE MINUTE SO I'M SO I KNOW
HOW MUCH LONGER YOUR AGE IS
GOING TO TAKE SO WE CAN BE SURE
OF TIME FOR QUESTIONS. MAYBE
ANOTHER FIVE. MAKE IT SURE THAT
WE GET. YEAH YOU MAY HAVE TEN
SO THAT THOSE ORIGINAL
ALLOCATED TIME SO AND I JUST
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS PEOPLE HAVE SO I
REALIZED I DON'T DEALS YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT WE WANT TO TRY
TO. GET TO THE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU SURE- I'M- ALL OF KEEP DOES
LEVEL SO THAT I CAN ANSWER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT'LL COME
OVER SO OUR STRATEGIC BREAKDOWN
OF OUR MEDIA. AND FOR THE- PAIN
IS LAUNCHING WITH FORTY
PERCENT- AND THE BEGINNING
FIRST FLIGHT THEN WE MOVED TO A
50% IN THE SECOND FLIGHT AND
10% SATISFIED FOR IN OUR- SO-
THAT IS THE STRATEGIC. BREAK
OUR MEDIA BY. I AM. AS FOR THE
FOR THOSE AT HOME IN OUR FOOD
IS NOT RESPONSE FOLLOW UP. YEAH
THANK YOU. I'M AND THEN DURING
ONE OF THE BIG DIFFERENTIATOR
BETWEEN OUR CAMPAIGN AND THE US
CENSUS BUREAU WHICH WAS VERY
STRATEGIC AS WERE USING STRESS
OF MESSENGERS TO LEAD WITH OUR
CAMPAIGN AND THAT'S- UP THE
BOTTOM. THAT'S WHETHER DOING IT
THROUGH CREATE ANY I DOING.
KING WITH OUR COMMUNITY THE
OBVIOUS THE OUTRAGE THAT DOES
NOT. BUT WITH THEM ONTO OUR
CAMP WE YOU. TRUSTED MUST. ON
RADIO FRIENDS AND THREE DID I
AM TO TELL IN THE CONTINUE THAT
THROUGHOUT THE CAMPAIGN. SURE
I'M I DO WANT TO MAKE A QUICK
MENTION ON ADDED VALUE OUR
CAMPAIGN HAS A RANGE BETWEEN
30% TO A HUNDRED PERCENT. EQUAL
VALUE ABOUT A VALUEMEDIA
PARTNERS I THINK THAT'S A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR CAMPAIGN
WHAT THAT MEANS IS IF THEY'VE A
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND I GIVE
THIRTY DOLLARS A NIGHT OR
SUMMER GIVE US A- DOLLAR. I AM
THAT WE CAN I GET. EACH OF ARMY
CAMP THE BILL IS DELIVER THAT
ADDED VALUE IN DIFFERENT COME.
I THINK ONE OF THE- THAT I WANT
MAKE I AM A- IS THAT I AM WITH
POLITICAL WINDOW THEY WE HAVE I
AM COMING UP YEAH WE- WORKED
WITH OUR PARTNERS VALLEY
UTILIZED- ARE ADDED VALUE TV TO
LAUNCH CAMPAIGN. SO THAT IS A
WAY FOR US TO LEVERAGE OUR
DOLLARS AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
GETTING ADDED YOU AT THE
BEGINNING I AM PAINTING- AND
WE- AT I'M AS- PLAY WITH. YOU
KNOW. OF OUR OTHER. TO MAKE
THAT ADDED VALUE RUN IN A
WINDOW AT THOSE BONUS MEDIA AND
THEN THE LAST BULLET POINT HERE
ON MICRO MEDIA I AM THE MICRO
MEDIA CAMPAIGNS WAS A UNIQUE
COMPONENT OF OUR IN THAT WE
DEVELOPED FROM COMING UP P. I'M
WHEN WE REACHED WE REALLY LIKE
IT IS THE STATEWIDE DAHLE. WE
WANTED I HAD A DOLLAR AMOUNT
MYERS PER READ. REALLY
CUSTOMIZE X. YOU ELEMENTS THAT
WERE REALLY. TO THE REGION. I
AM AND SOME OF THAT NEEDED TO
BE DETERMINED AFTER OF THE
STATEWIDE MADE BY WAS
COMPLETELY PLANNED AND WE COULD
START TO WORK WITH THE REGION
TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THAT WITHOUT.
AN ONLY BE HAPPY PLACE. I WELL
ACTUALLY MEN. THOUSAND UNDER.
BE RIO THEN LEAVE FOR READ
SEVEN. FROM A IN A JUDGE ARE
YOU JUST WANTED TO DO SPEAK TO
HELP THAT SHE WORKED WITH IN A
REGION GIVEN. WE RECEIVE THE
STATE PLANNING DECEMBER AND
ACTUALLY THAN BY WAS ALSO
RELEASED THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
REGIONAL SINCE THIS YEAR'S
WE'RE BUT SINCE THE GAPS FIND
OPPORTUNITIES SURVEY THE NEEDS
WERE ABLE TO SERVE OUR- NEEDS
OF OUR A CBO. BILLS IN EVEN. A
PART. THEN WORKSHOPS. AND THEN
THE INCREASE CAN CUT BY THE
SIEMENS ACOSTA PLANS THAT WERE
WITH THE NEEDS OF EACH REGION-
SO I'LL- BRIEFLY GO TO GO TO
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN ALSO THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEAD- FOR THE
RECTORY TEAM AND- MY CHARGE
THERE IS TO HELP MOTIVATE THE
HARDEST ACCOUNT AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO PARTICIPATE. I DID
YOU THAT IS THE ELEMENT THAT
MATCH THE ODD ABOUT RESTED
MESSENGER I THINK CHANNELS WE
THIRTY ONE. BLACK OWNED MEDIA
PARTNERS WE ARE WORKING.
MISSION WE HAVE TO RETIRE PAID.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE. OUR BEDS WE
HAVE JOURNALISM THAT WE ARE
HELPING THEM PRODUCE- IN THE
PROCESS AND THEY WERE ALSO WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS SO BESIDES
THE CHANNEL OF THOSE MEDIA
OUTLETS. A LIST OF COMPOUND
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED NOW WITH
START UP TO THREE HUNDRED. AND
RICK BASED PATIENTS NOT
CONTRACTED WITH. SEE THOSE THAT
IS OUR- IS. OF FOR TWO TO. THE
RECORD. WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
USE THEIR CHANNELS WELL TO
DELIVER THOSE MESSAGES- I KNOW
ADMITTED TURNED OVER TO JESSICA
MY- COLLEAGUES TO TALK A LITTLE.
YEAH I'M JUST. THE FIRST IS
THAT OUR MEDIA PARTNERSHIPS ARE
NOT JUST ABOUT ADVERTISING THEY
ARE ALSO ABOUT DRIVING
EDITORIAL CONTENT SO THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT JUST SEEING
ANSWER ALSO SEE WHAT LOOKS LIKE
JOURNALISM AND IN MANY CASES IT
IS YOU KNOW UP IT IS AN
JOURNALIST WRITING A STORY. HE
SAYS WE'RE- LEFT PARTNER
EXAMPLE WE BURKE AYE WITH ME HE
WHO IS THE EIGHT COMPLETE HELPS
CO CHAIR HERE AND COUNTY FOR
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR WITH AN OP
ED FOR HER SACRAMENTO BEE BUT
THAT ALSO GET IT OUT AT THE END.
IN TWENTY. AND THIRD PIECE THAT
WE- THE- MEDIA ANY MEDIA
PARTNERS WE ARE BOTH TO PRO OUT
IN REACTIVE WERE MEANING THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THAT MISSING
INFORMATION IS. THEY AT THIS
GROUP PARTNERS IS GOING TO CALL
AS MAKE SURE THAT ARE CORRECT
INFORMATION IS OUT THROUGH
TRUSTED MASSINGER'S ON TRUSTED
PLATFORMS. OKAY THANK YOU. YOU
ACTUALLY USE IT USE ADDITIONAL
SIX MINUTES FROM THE TIME THE
REST SO SORRY BUT I JUST RIGHT.
QUESTION THANK YOU. WELL I TH
START. QUESTION RIGHT NOW ARE
OKAY LET ME THROW OUT ONE FOR
THE QUESTION I JUST WANT TO BE
SURE WE- THE WAY THINGS- THAT.
I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM FOLKS IS
THAT SO THAT I WANT YOU TO
ASSIST- HOW. THREE IS. THE WITH
OTHER I I'LL TELL YOU THAT- I
WAS LOOKING STERN TO HEAR THAT
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE DONE LIKE
MESSAGE TESTING AND SO FORTH-
BUT PEOPLE I MEAN YOU'RE USING
IT. MOLLY BUT- SO ARE. ARE ABLE
THAT INFORMATION. OH OKAY
SELVES SO THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I APPRECIATE YOU
ADDRESSING BECAUSE YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE YOUR DOING THE WORK
YOU'RE EXPERTS BUT YOU KNOW
WE'RE PAYING FOR IT WE SHOULD
BE SURE OF EVERYBODY RIGHT UP
BUT IT SHOULD BE. IN HIS. THE
OTHER IS THAT SO IN TERMS. THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN YOUR MEDIA
EFFORTS AND- WE HAVE A CBO
DOESN'T TO ME PARTNERS AND HOW
THAT INTERFACE IS WORKING SO I
THINK THERE'S BEEN FUSION I'VE
BEEN HEARING I'M- AT. PARTNERS
ABOUT WHAT THREE DOING AND WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING FOR AND WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO AND HAVING CLIP
THIRTY ON THAT- SO THAT I DO
I'M SURE YOU GET THIS QUESTIONS
OUT RIGHT NOW SO WE CAN PLEASE
ADDRESS THOSE. SURE ALL. YOUR
FIRST ONE AND THEN I'LL TURN.
THE MESSAGE TESTING I. MINUTES
AGO WE LOOK WE LAY THE
FOUNDATION FROM OUR CAMPAIGN
BASED ON ANALYZING A PLETHORA
OF EXISTING RESEARCH THAT WAS
COMPLETED- BOTH BEFORE WE ARE
ON CONTRACT AND THEN SOME OF IT
FINISHED JUST IN THE FIRST PART
OF OUR ENGAGEMENT AND WE
PRODUCED. THE UP IN. THE BRAIN
AND NOW THIS IF WILL OF ALL OF
THAT EXISTING RESEARCH IN MAY
THAT AVAILABLE TO PARTNERS
SINCE THEN WE'VE LOST LAUNCH
OUR OWN THREE PART MESSAGE
TESTING STRATEGY WHICH
INCLUDES- FOCUS GROUPS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ACTUALLY THE LAST OF WHICH WAS
JUST LAST NIGHT FOR THE FULL
PHASE IN REGION IN LOS ANGELES
IN THE ARMENIAN SPEAKING
COMMUNITY. SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE WANT TO COMPILE A
COMPREHENSIVE. AFTER THE FIRST
AND SHARE WITH THAT'S THE PLAN.
IT'S JUST THAT THEY'VE BEEN
ROLLING OUT ACROSS THE AND WE-
FEEL LIKE WE CAN OKAY. MEANING
ON THEIR OWN WE WANT. SOMETHING
ONE HOPE PERHAPS ESPECIALLY
WE'RE RUNNING. I AM NOT BUT IT.
IS THE. ONE OF THE BIG REPORT
ABOUT. BY AND IT CAN SAID HEY
GIVE ME THE ON I TRYING TO MESS
THIS TO ME THE DATA YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW HOW BUT A MESSAGE
THIS SO THERE SOMEBODY WHO AT
MERCURY COULD BE THE POINT
PERSON THAT I HAVE SOMEONE WHO
SAYS. YOU KNOW I DON'T AND READ
BIG REPORT I ONLY HAVE TWO
WEEKS LEFT I'M- GREAT DOING.
ANGEL RIPPING PART. BUT I'M
ACTUALLY ON THIS GROUP YOU MY
HAVE DATA ON THAT. CAN YOU TELL
ME WHAT THE MESSAGING
INFORMATION IS. FOR THAT GROUP
OF PEOPLE RIGHT AND DEL WITHOUT
HAVING TO WAIT FOR A BIG REPORT
READ A BIG REPORT. BE ABLE TO
SO THEY CAN MOVING BECAUSE
THEY'RE TRYING TO ACT TO THEIR
ON A SHORT TIME I TO WERE ALL
RUSHING TOWARD. PEOPLE FOR
THAT'S RIGHT SO. YES I AT
MARTHA DOMINGUEZ WHO USE ON THE
COULD REALLY IN. DAY AND-
BACKING WELL THE- THING WITH
ARMY TESTING PARTNER SO I'D SAY.
WE HAVE ALL YOUR EMAIL JUST
LIKE THAT YEAH OKAY- AND HAPPY
TO CONTINUE ALL RIGHT AND I
HOPE THAT- THAT WAY HERE FROM
BACK FROM PEOPLE AND I. DON'T
KNOW IF THEY ACTUALLY GOT.
YOU'RE NOT IS THAT. IN A-
SPEEDO WHATEVER IT IS THEY WILL
SHARE LIKE. WAIT A MINUTE
WHAT'S THAT SUPPOSED TO MEAN
CELL OKAY. ALL RIGHT AND THEN
YOU ADDRESS THE OTHER QUESTION
ABOUT- COORDINATION WITH. LOCAL
SO WHERE IS THE DIVIDING LINE
BETWEEN LOCAL AND- TERM
THEMSELF. WHAT YOU'RE
CONTRACTED WITH SO I AM WE ARE
PROVIDING WE STARTED IN AT THE
BEGINNING OF DECEMBER PROVIDING
A LIST OF MEDIA THAT WE WOULD
BE I'M PUTTING INTO. THIS I'M
FOR ALL OF OUR MEDIA PARTNERS.
AND WE PROVIDED THAT TALLER
PARTNERS NEVER. ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED OR PLUS. A COMPANY THAT
WE SEE. THE FOLKS LOOK AT
CONTRACTING WITH BECAUSE AT
THAT TIME. AND HAVE OUR
CONTRACTS MY- AND- IN JANUARY
WE HAD ANOTHER PER CALL AND WE
ACTUALLY PERCENT PROVIDED- THAT
LIST AGAIN IN FINAL FORM AS
WELL AS A FLOW CHART OF OUR
MEDIA PLAN- SINCE THEN WE'VE
HAD INDIVIDUAL. MEETINGS AND
WORKSHOPS WITH THEIR PLANS-
THROUGH OUR MARKET MIKE MIKE
REMEDIATE LANES AND WITH THE
CENSUS OFFICE. AND IN THOSE
MEETINGS WE- PROVIDED NOT ONLY
GAP ANALYSIS FOR THE REGION'S
BASED ON THE MEDIA BY FOR THE
STATE AND THE US CENSUS. I AND
THEM TO WORKSHOP IDEAS AND IN
LIKE THE NEXT WEEK THEY SHOULD
BE GETTING FINAL APPROVED MEDIA
PLANS- FOR THE MICROMETER ABOUT
ICE. OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT
SERVE GOOD DESCRIPTION OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING I'M NOT SURE I
HEARD EXACTLY THE ANSWER MY
QUESTIONS SOME OF YOUR THE CBO
LET'S SAY YOU'RE IN SACRAMENTO.
WHAT ARE. WHAT IS IT THAT
MERCURY'S GOOD DO I NEED A GOOD
CELL AT DESCRIPTION VERSUS WHAT
ARE WE STUCK WITH HAVING TO DO
AND TERMS OF COMMUNICATING
LET'S SAY WITH BUT THEY'VE PI
COMMUNITY ARE SOME YELLED. IT'S
THE IT'S PROBABLY NOT WHAT OUT
PRIORITY BUT SACRAMENTO BEE
SURE SAY BUT- IT WAS WERE
TRYING TO TARGET PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES WHERE WHERE'S THE
LINE BETWEEN WHAT MERGERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR AND WHAT THE A.
B. L. ORDER. PARTNERS A WRIST
FOR TERMS. BE ACTIVE. BUT OF
LOCAL NEWS. THAT SO THERE'S TWO
THERE'S TWO ON THE QUESTION THE
FUNDING WE HAVE SAID IF I FOR
THE REACH AT STACY MENTIONED
THAT. BEEN THE CENTER OF THE
WORKS MEETINGS THAT SHE CRIED I
THINK WE'VE HAD AT LEAST TWO IF
NOT THREE WITH A HEARING REGION
ONE FOR. ALL AND THAT MY- MEDIA
PLANS COMING TOGETHER AS WE
SPEAK TODAY THE SECOND I THINK
PART OF THAT THOUGH IS THE-
INDICATE STOP THEY MIGHT HAVE.
THEIR OWN KIND BY WAY OF THEIR-
PLANS AND THAT. BY THIS THOMAS
OKAY. THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
SOME STRUGGLES TO FIGURE OUT
LIKE BECAUSE HAVE TO BUDGET IS
WHAT I THE BUDGET FOR I KNOW
WHAT A SUPPOSED WHERE. I'M
SUPPOSED TO DO PURSES. THE A
SUPERIOR THE BIG MEDIA
ORGANISATIONS SO. OKAY I THINK
THAT PROP THAT WAS AND WE'VE
WORKED TOGETHER WITH ALL OF THE
REGIONS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A
LOT OF TRANSPARENCY AND WORK
TOGETHER AND I KNOW HOW LIKE
CAN PROBABLY SPEAK TO THAT IN
HER REGION BUT IN. IN ART AND
THEIR GENES THAT. OTHER THAN
HER GEN YOU HAVE DONE THAT AS
WELL. OKAY GOOD OKAY ALL RIGHT
WELL I'D AND I'M LOOKING FOR
HEARING FROM PEOPLE. OKAY I
CERTAINLY HAVE. MORE QUESTIONS
BUT I- BUT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND SO AS A MEMBER RAMOS YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN AGAIN-
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK IN MAKING SURE THE HARD TO
COUNT AREAS ARE BEING
ADDRESSED- AND ONE OF THOSE IS
WITH THE CONSULTING GROUP-
NINA. AND THERE ARE THEY
THEY'RE NOT HERE TODAY RIGHT.
SO WITH THE ONE OF THE HARDEST-
AREAS HARD TO REACH AREAS BEING
NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION-
MISTER CHAIR OF THERE'S A WAY
THATI CAN MEET WITH THEM. IN
MY OFFICE TO FIND OUT TRULY
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN- COMMUNITY OF HOW
WE'RE DOING THAT OUT REACH. ONE
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALSO
URBAN. THERE ARE. I KNOW.
CHAIRMAN BERMAN BROUGHT UP AS
FAR AS THE USE OF INTERNET NET
AND THOSE TYPES OF WEB PORTALS.
WE KNOW IT- ABOUT IN COUNTRIES
HERE IN THIS THE CALIFORNIA-
STILL IS AREAS THAT LACK I'M
INTERNET ACCESS. SO HOW ARE WE-
ABLE TO REACH OUT TO THOSE AND
I KNOW THERE'S- BEEN SOME WORK.
OURS LOOK AT RADIO. TIMES
BENSON AND NEW IN THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS SO HOW WE NARROWED IT
DOWN. IN IS THE OF THE FAT. I'M
DOING. THEN IRVINE AMERICAN
POPULAR. SO ALL SPEAK LARGE TO
THE LARGE LOW PRICE. POINT THAT
IT'S BECAUSE- WONDER I'M WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF TACTICS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING THOSE
WITH WITH LOW BROADBAND IN THE
BROADBAND AREAS ON THAT INCLUDE
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT WE CALL OUT
OF HOME ADVERTISING TACTICS
THAT MIGHT BE IN THE MOVIE
THEATER IT MIGHT BE A REALLY
CUSTOMIZED UP PIECE OF SIGNAGE
AURORA. WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. REYES
AS YOU MIGHT AS WELL AS-
WATCHING THE ICC APARTMENT MY
PURPOSE HERE BUT THE DIGITAL.
THE DIGITAL CAPABILITY OF
SOMETHING TO LOAD ON A MOBILE
PHONE SATURDAY RIGHT WATCHING
WHERE THOSE LOW BROADBAND AREAS
ARE AFFECTED FROM A DIGITAL
POINT. AND WILL WORK ARE
WORKING IN WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH NEW NET AS WELL AS
THE OTHER NATIVE AMERICAN
PARTNERS THAT SIMULATED EARLIER
ABOUT. A MINUTE WHICH IS WITH
THE FEDERALLY WRECKED STRIPES
VERSUS THE OTHER. ONE AND I'VE
JUST ON THE BECAUSE WE'RE IN
THE SAME SAME REGION WE HAVE A
LOT OF TRIBES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT ARE A MICRO MEDIA
PLAN IS TARGETING SO THAT CAME
FROM FRANKLY FOR. TV CBO DOING
WORK IN THE REGION. HAVE MORE
AVERAGE. TO THOSE COMMUNITY.
SOME OF THE OUT SO WOULD BE
STORE SIGNAGE THAT RIGHT THERE
IN THE IN THE RURAL A- I'M SO
THAT WILL. TO THE MICRO MEDIA
PLAN WILL BE ABLE TO COVER SOME
OF THAT AT LEAST IN OUR REGION
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT LOOK
LIKE IN THE OTHER REGIONS NINE
AND THANK YOU FOR. THROUGH
BECAUSE OF IT'S POSSIBLE TO GET
A SUMMARY REPORT OF THAT OUT
REACH UP FROM THEM TO THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY ON
BOTH THE FEDERALLY IN URBAN
AREAS SO THAT WE COULD THEN BE
A CATALYST TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT. AND SHIP OUT
TO THE HARD. WHAT HE SAID YEAH
TAKE CARE THAT GET WILL. YOU AS
WELL SENATOR NOTHING OKAY ALL
RIGHT. OKAY A FEW QUESTIONS AND
BEFORE WE GET TO THIS JUST A
QUICK AND NOW WITH THE WHAT'S
THE DEAL PUBLICADO THEIR SIGN
IN LIST THERE. OKAY RIGHT NOW
OKAY SO I WANT ABOUT SIGNING
POST GIVE NO OKAY WITH US. OKAY
JUST ONE CHECK. ALL RIGHT SO-
THE HAS A MEMBER OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER CAUCUS SO AT
THE CAUCUS AT IT'S A REAL QUICK
THE ONE ASK. PASSED UP SO FIRST
QUOTE BREAK. HOW MERCURY SPLIT
UP GENERAL. MEETING THE
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES IN THE API
COMMUNITY IS THERE BREAKDOWN
FOR HOW THOSE AT THE MEDIA
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT- SO CAN
WE GET PERMISSION ON HOW YOU'RE
BASICALLY DRESSING AT THE MEET
AND AT THE END SO YOU. THE
THREE EIGHTY I PERHAPS MORE I'M
BACK QUESTION WOULDYOU BE
COMFORTABLE WITH US PROVIDING
YOU A SUMMARY THE SAME WE WERE
DOING THAT AND- YEAH. YES YEAH
YES. THANK YOU YOU CAN JUST BE
PERHAPS A LITTLE AT IN TERMS OF
COUPLE TOPLINE ANSWERS TO THAT
I DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC OKAY
PERCENTAGES ON I WOULDN'T WANNA
MISTER MISTER OKAY BUT I CAN'T
DO WE HAVE A STRATEGIC AND THAT
DOES GET OUT THE WAY THAT YOU
ASKED. PROVIDE A. AREAS AND I
KNOW YOU TOUCHED ON SOME OF IT
BEFORE YOU PRESENTATION
PREVIOUS ANSWER TO ME- ANY OF
ANYTHING IT TO ADD TO THAT. I
THINK. WHAT THE IRA BUT
CERTAINLY- WE TO DIE LIKE WE
WANT TO CONTINUE THROUGHOUT THE
CAMPAIGN SAYS OKAY WITH THAT
OKAY AND THEN- YOU KNOW WE DID
SET THIS BUREAU ITSELF THE U.
S. HAS PART OF NATIONAL TV
INCLUDE TO EIGHT B. C. B. S. TO
RULE OUT COMMUNICATION
EDUCATION THERE SOMETHING TAP
THAT US. STATE LAW ALSO THE
COURT. THE NATIONAL GROUPS OF
STATE EIGHTY I GROUPS THAT A IS
AMERICA ADVANCING JUSTICE THE
ON THE OUT REACH. OF SO HOW HOW
HOW RECORD EIGHTY FOR LET'S
EIGHT EIGHTY COMMUNITY.
NATIONALLY AND FROM THE
MESSAGING CONTENT. I AM I WILL
TELL YOU THAT I'M WE ARE NOT
PRIVY TO THE US CENSUS BUREAU
BUT I THINK MESSAGE IS IN
ADVANCE BUT BUT I CAN'T. WE ARE
TRYING VERY COORDINATED FOR I'M
EVERY LEVEL THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
TOUCH AND THAT MOST OF THOSE
ARE THE- MEDIA AND THE CBO IS
THAT ARE. IN OUR STATE AND THEN
ALSO I COUNTY DOES NOT COME
MARIO WORKING A LOT OF. BIG
ACTUALLY WITH PART BUT THEN THE
COMMUNITY HELP THE EIGHTY
MESSAGE. MIGHT OUR SITE. LOVES
ABOUT. IN LEAVE AND I DON'T
KNOW AIMS ME BUT IT. WE CAN
PROVIDE THANKS THE NAMES YEAR
WITH OUR SO. WELL OKAY AS AND
AS MEDIA. AS ARE SENT. WITH
RESPECT TO A P. I NEED AND THEY
HAVE MUCH LIKE COLOR STRATEGY
WITH THE AFRICA AMERICAN MEET.
THEY'RE LEVERAGING BOTH MEDIA
AND TRADITIONAL AND SAN AS WELL
AS COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ANY OF US INTELLIGENCE ABOUT
THAT MEDIA REACHES AND MANY.
AUDIENCE ON THE SIDE I KNOW AND
YEAH I JUST KIND OUR TEAM OF
HAVE BEEN ALSO COORDINATION
WITH OF THOSE FOR STRESS RIGHT
SO I WE ADD THAT. ON THAT. WE
ARE ALSO WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR COVERAGE ON
EDITORIAL CONTENT SUCH THAT. IF
THE MEDIA BRIEFING. EVEN THOSE
THAT MAY NOT HAVE ADVERTISING
DOLLARS DEVOTED TO THEM WE ARE
BRINGING FOR WORKING WITH OUR
SUBCONTRACTORS MAKES THAT THERE
IS. LIGHT YOUR- AND MEDIA THAT
I'VE A THIEF ON THE OTHER CUT
BUT I MEAN API OUT READ ISN'T
JUST AT THAT MEDIA. WRITERS
MESSAGING TO EIGHTY EIGHT IS
THAT A NOT GO THROUGH I THINK
MEDIA SO I'LL GIVE YOU A CALL
YEAH- WITH OUR STATE. JOHNNY
PARTNERS THEY'VE BEEN IN TOUCH
WITH US ABOUT SOME OF OUR
MESSAGING AND WE'RE APPLYING
SOME OF THEIR INSIGHTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE ENHANCING THE MESSAGE
SUCH THAT IT TOUCHES. ANY GIVEN
ODD AUDIENCE IN THE MOST HI. SO
A LOT OF TIMES WE'RE GETTING
FEEDBACK AS OUR MESSAGES IS
BEING ARE BEING DEPLOYED
PARTICULARLY DIGITAL BASS AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PUTTING OUT-
THERE THE RIGHT MESSAGE TO THE
RIGHT. I IN THE MOST CULTURALLY.
OKAY SO WHEN ARE YOU GONNA BE A
GIVE ME THE INFORMATION ON WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AT THE A. T. I.
COMMUNITY. I THINK THAT'S I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN.
HIGHLIGHT IN IN THE SUMMARY
MORE SO THEN IT WENT AWAY AND
WHAT I GET THE INFORMATION-
WE'RE WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
TOMORROW SURE OKAY PROVIDE YOUR
SUMMARY ALL RIGHT BECAUSE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME AND THERE'S
AND YEAH SO I HAVE TO THEM LOW
FRUSTRATE YOU DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION WITH YOU HERE TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT YEAH
BECAUSE WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME- ENGINE YOU SPEAK TO YOU
MENTION SOCIAL MEDIA IN THE
ROLE OF NOW I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
FOCUSING ON THE HARD TO COUNT
POPULATION NOT NECESSARY
EVERYONE THERE'S ON SOCIAL
MEDIA- I THINK I DO FOLLOW THE
SOAP IMMEDIATE OUT BUT I WOULD
MAKE NO BETTER DOES FOUR
THOUSAND FALL CALPERS FORTY.
THOUSAND BRAG SORRY. HE AND I
DON'T REACH EVERYONE CALIFORNIA
FORTY THOUSAND WITH A FORTY
DOLLAR ALIVE IS NOT RUNS ALSO
STATED SO IT IS THERE WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLAN I
NATIVE AND THEM BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THINGS LIKE THIS
GEN AND SO FORTH SO THAT'S WHAT
THE ERROR IF. YEAH I YOU HAVE A
TWITTER ACCOUNT HERE FOR THE
FALL BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S JUST THE THAT SAYS
DROPPED NO EGGS IN ONE OF OUR
GOALS AND JUSTICE EDUCATING AN
ACT. WELL AS I ALSO THE BILL WE
HAVE EIGHT SOCIAL ME THAT IS
THE DO JUST THAT SOMETHING UP
IN TANDEM WITH THE SAN CATIONS
TEAM AND I IN TEN YEARS. I ON A-
MILLER. MILLER WE HAVE ALL UST
BE ON WERE WITH SOCIAL MEDIA
AND- ARM OR AND BACK. AS
CALLING. TO REALLY BILL ADDING
IN A MORE ON. ORGANIC WAY SUCH
THEY ALREADY HAVE LARGE
FOLLOWINGS LIKE YOURSELF AND
CAN PUT OUR MESSAGES OUT THERE
AND REALLY BUSY WRITING THAT
TRICKS YOUR- ESTABLISHING IN
TERMS OF LIKE WHAT YOU TRY HOW
MANY YOU'RE TRYING TO REACH. I
WE ARE MEASURING THEM WE ARE
WATCHING HOW THEY GROW I HAVE-
YEAH WE HAVE GOALS AND WE'RE
AND WE'RE WATCHING HOW CAN BE
DOES NOT TODAY. OKAY WITH ME TO
WRITE SO WE CAN GET THOSE I
THINK I KNOW CENTER BECAUSE
HERE'S RIGHT AND METRICS OKAY
SO WITH. WE LIKED AND- POLLS
ARE. AND TERMS. HE DOES TRICKS
SIR AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER
THING IS THAT YOU KNOW WERE OF
HIS THE SENSES IS A MULTI.
MONTH WERE RAMPING UP SO- SO
SHOULD WE AND WE HEARD ACTUALLY
FROM MANY MEMBERS- AS THEY WERE
COMING IN AND OUT. SINCE WHAT
THE STAFF BUT THEY SAID WELL IN
A WHOLE LOT I HAVEN'T HEARD A
WHOLE LOT OKAY- SO WHAT SHOULD
OUR AND I REALIZE THAT WERE
HERE PROBABLY NOT PART. MEMBERS
AND MANY HARD COPULATIONS- CAN
YOU DESCRIBE WHAT SHOULD WE BE
EXPERIENCING SO WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE INVESTMENT OF WHICH YOU
HAVE A BIG CHUNK YOU GOTTA BE
CONTRACT- THIS SHOULD BE
EXPERIENCING WE HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT ARE DOLLARS WERE SPENT THE
PROBABLY THE SO WHY THINGS. AND
SAYS CITIZENS AND ELSE WHAT
SHOULD WE BE SEEING ON OUR
NEWSPEAK NEWSPAPERS TV IN OUR
SOCIAL MEDIA IS AND SO FORTH
DESCRIBE TO ME STARTING OUT ONE
AN UP AND MARCH OR SOMETHING
WILL START SEE. ABOUT I
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY FOR IT MEANT
I DO BECAUSE I'M INTEREST ISN'T
CLOSE STUFF UP THIS IS THE YES
BUT I'M ALSO HEARING JUST HERE
IN THIS VERY HEARING SO I IT
OWN CALL SAYING WHAT. YEAH
DOING BUDDY PLEASE HELP. AND
THE KNOWLEDGE IN I THINK THAT'S
THE HER PART OF THIS BECAUSE IS
WE FOCUSED ON THE HARD ACCOUNT
POPULATION WHICH MEAN WERE
BEING HARD AND WAY THAT WE ARE
DELIVERING OUR MEDIA I'M OUR
TEAM DID A VERY STRATEGIC
APPROACH TO THE BY DOING AN
OVERLAY OF ONLY TRYING TO BUY
YEAH HEART. A DOESN'T. REACHES
I FIVE. SISTERS OUR INTO THE
SPELL BEEN MINE MOST OF OUR
MEDIA IS IN THE AT WERE NOT
BUYING GEN PRICE IF YOU SEE IT
DOT IF YOU'RE ON A GENERAL
BROADCAST STATION LIKE A EASIER
THE STATE YOU'RE REALLY THE
THING THE US CENSUS BUREAU ADS
IF YOU SEE AN AD ON THURMOND
THAT'LL KIND OF. TENDER LIKE
YOU'RE SAYING. OUR OUR IN OUR
PLACE. IN YOUR PROP SEE OUR OF
HOMES THE MOST IN THE CENSUS
TRACK AREAS BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
WE'RE PLACING THEM. THAT'S
GONNA BE THE MOST VISUAL- THING
THAT YOU'LL PROBABLY SEEN. OUR
HOPES IS THAT YOU'RE NOT SERVED
AND ALL ADAM SO I WANTED TO OUR
AS A ONE TIME RIGHT. OVER
BECAUSE WE'RE BEING VERY GET IT
IN THE WAY THAT WERE. ALSO YEAH
WE DID EXPRESS LESS CONCERN
BECAUSE IT ISN'T IT IS A LOT OF
MONEY YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SEE HE WOULD. ONLY SEE
AND GENERAL. TRACK SHOP PLACE
THAT YOU. MORE WE WILL BE TÁI
BUT IT A LITTLE MORE I GENERAL
I'M OUT REACHES SOCIAL WILL BE
SAME WAY BECAUSE THERE
AUDIENCES AREN'T TARGETED TO
OUR AMHERST RELATIONS. I PRINCE
IS ANOTHER ONE THAT I THINK
YOU'LL BE ABLE IT WILL BE A
GOOD PLACE FOR YOU TO PICK UP
AND SEE THINGS- I EARNS MEDIA
WHEN. JESSICA CAME IS FANTASTIC
I'M GETTING NEWS COVERAGE ABOUT
IS ALSO GOING TO NOT BE AND
THAT THIS ACCOUNT POPULATIONS
THAT IS GOING TO BE AN- RULING
WAS RESPONSIBLE THING TO COVER
IT SO I THINK. IS A GOOD.
POLICY THE YEAH I'M FROM OUR-
I'M- WE DO. AND HAS OVER DEL
BIRD ON METRICS I'M I'M FROM AN
INDUSTRY STANDARD IN SOME CASES
DOUBLE THE INDUSTRY STANDARD
AND I'LL SHARE WITH YOUR ISSUE
STANDARDS ARE BASED ON EVERYONE
NOT THE HARDEST OF COUNTY
ELATION SO UNDERSTAND THAT MEET
OUR CAMPAIGN IS PERFORMING EVEN
BETTER THAT THE NUMBERS
ACTUALLY SO EASY DOUBLE WIDE
WHAT'S THE MEASURE I'M WELL
THERE'S A ACTUALLY. WHEN WE-
AND GET. TO USE. SHOP CLICK
THROUGH I'M ALL OF A CLEAN
HIGHER AND I PULLED THE NUMBER
UP ON MY FOR IN CASE WE WANTED
TO BILL THAT LIKE HAVE IT BUT I
WANT YOU KNOW FOR US. MATT
THANKS GOING TO BE. STANDARDS A
ON. RELATION AND OUR CAMP. IS A-
MORE FOR. RIGHT SO. WHEN WERE
SAYING DOUBLE THE INDUSTRY
STANDARD WHATEVER THAT NUMBER
IS. WE'RE DELIVERING EVEN
BETTER THAN WHAT THAT
REPRESENTS BECAUSE OF THE
TARGETED NESS OF THIS CAMPAIGN
AND THE WAY THAT WE HAVE TO
REACH VERY SPECIFIC- MEMBERS OF
OUR STATE- SO I'M- I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION ON WHAT
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO. SEE
RIGHT NOW IT'S HARD. TO I
THINK- IS BOTH FOR YOU. I THINK
FOR THE CENSUS STAFF IS IN THE
AUDIENCE. IS GOING TO. IT I
THINK ONE OF THINGS THAT MIGHT
BE HELPFUL IS FIGURE OUT HOW TO
COMMUNICATE WITH PROBABLY A
DISTRICT OFFICES IN THE
LEGISLATURE. WHAT IS ACTUALLY.
DIFFERENT PEOPLE- I THANK EL
WAY TO COMMUNICATE LIKE LOOK
YOU KNOW WE'RE LIKE HERE'S A
LIST OF ALL THE OP ED AT AND
WHERE YOU'RE PUBLISHED RATE
THAT'S IN A STRICT THERE
SOMETHING LKE THAT I REALIZE
IT'S A LITTLE EXTRA TIME TO DO
BUT- THIS. IS NOT. RISING
TARGET ARE THE COUNT FIVE. THAT
TRYING TO FIGURE HOW TO MAKE
THAT. MORE THE OTHER THING THAT
I JUST WANNA SAY IS THAT IT'S
IF. YEAH I THINK. IN TERMS OF
CONFIDENCE BUILDING- THIS MUCH-
SHARING AS POSSIBLE YOUR THEME
HERE SHARING SHARING
INFORMATION SHARING WORK.
ETCETERA AND- WE HAVE TO.
FORMATION TRANSFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS BUT- NO BUT I THINK
THE MORE OF THE ARE ABOUT WE'RE
DOING- THAT IS GOING TO. ALSO I
THINK. PEOPLE GET EARNERS LIKE
WHEN THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON AND THEY'RE NOT.
ANYTHING AT ALL LIKE WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON IT AND- GREAT. DANTE
AND TO WORK OUT BUT. FOURTH
BECAUSE PEOPLE OTHER PEOPLE
COULD USE THAT YOU COULD USE
INFORMATION TO HELP THEM TO
WRITE SO WE SHOULD BE SHARING
ALL THE RESOURCES TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAXIMIZE. EVERYBODY IT'S
NOT ABOUT INDIVIDUAL
PERFORMANCE IN THE END IT'S
ABOUT OUR COLLECTIVE
PERFORMANCE WHICH IS GONNA BE
RESPECTED BY WHAT THE FINAL
COUNT IS. ONLY FINISH YOUR
SENSES AT A AT ULTIMATELY
THAT'S THE TRUE MEASURE OF OUR
SUCCESS WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE-
METRIC IN WHICH IS WHY. THE
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO IS WHO IS
THIS THING ROLLS OUT WITH THAT
IF I GAPS AND HOLES HOW WE
BECAUSE IN THE END. YOU'LL IT
REALLY MATTERS IS THAT WE
CANNOT EVERYBODY ARE NOT. HOW
YOU KNOW HOW CLOSE WE GOT THAT
RIGHT SO- SO I KNOW WHAT I HAVE
IN YOUR METRICS FOR INDIVIDUAL
PARTNER PEOPLE DID THEY DO THAT
THE VISUAL JOB LOSS OF. BUT ALL
THE ONLY. OF SISTER RIGHT AND
OF. THIS IS A KIND OF IN THE-
PEOPLE THAT REALLY WELL.
BECAUSE THAT SO WELL BE.
SOMEONE DIDN'T KNOW SOMETHING
THAT'S ELSE. AN COULD YOU IT AT
THE TIME. AT THE TIME. WHICH
COULD HAVE MADE. THEN WE
DIDN'T. AND IT DIDN'T WORK
RIGHT SO. THAT'S YOU KNOW SO I
KNOW EVERYONE HAS A PEACE BUT
ALSO HOW TO BE SURE COORDINATE
SHARE INFORMATION BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WE DON'T KNOW. COULD
BE USEFUL TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
UNLESS IT. IS PROBABLY MAKE
SURE THINGS ARE AS PUBLIC AS
POSSIBLE. SO WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE- AIMING AT. THAT MAKES
SENSE. OKAY OUR THAT I AND
FORTY HAVE TO OUT FOR A FEW
MORE. OF SONG OF IT ON TO CHEER
BROUGH HOOSIER WHO I KNOW IT'S
BEEN. PATIENT WITH. HAS HIS OWN
QUESTION AND I. WILL TRY TO GET
BACK. THANK YOU DON'T HAVE
BEEN- AND A LOT OF THE- IN
ORDER QUESTIONS OF AN COVERED
SO. I DON'T HAVE A LOT TO ADD
ALL THIS COOKIE REEMPHASIZE A
COUPLE THINGS OF AS YOU CAN
TELL THERE'S NO LACK OF THIRST
FOR DATA- AND SO DON'T BE SHY
THE MORE THE BETTER- THE EITHER
HEARING A LITTLE- ANXIETY- AS
AS WE CLOSER AND CLOSER TO
MARCH TWELFTH AND THEN APRIL
FIRST AND IT IS. CAN GET IN FOR
THE BETTER. MY HAVE FALL
QUESTIONS AND A LOT OF THINGS
THAT YOU'LL HEAR FROM US CHAIR
IS WERE FUNNELING OUR
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS THAT THEY'VE- RAISED
US- ON A REGULAR BASIS-
BECAUSE- THIS IS THIS ISSUE IS
BECOMING A LOT MORE REAL- AS AS
WE GET CLOSER TO. FOLKS
RECEIVING THOSE LETTERS IN THE
MAIL SO. IT ALL YOU'RE DOING
APPRECIATE ALL THAT THAT YOU
CAN PROVIDE TO KIND OF CLARIFY
SOME THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
RAISED TODAY- I ALSO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE- USE THAT
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR- LOCAL
PARTNERS- SO THAT THEY CAN YOU
KNOW IN MY OFFICE ON THE BOTTLE
NECK ON EVERYTHING. THERE ARE
TIMES. AND IT AYE AYE IN ORDER
MYSELF BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I'M
STOPPING MY STAFF FROM REALLY
GOING FORWARD AND- YOU KNOW
DOING THE 99% OF THE WORK THAT
THEY DO- BECAUSE I HAVEN'T.
MADE A DECISION- GOT AN ANSWER-
SO WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING THE LOCAL FOLKS-
THE THEN FOR THAT THEY NEED SO
THAT THEY CAN- EXPEND THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE AND
EXECUTE THEIR PLANS- A COUPLE
QUESTIONS I JUST WANT TO TOUCH
UPON. YOU MENTIONED SO FOR ME
THE INFLUENCE OR SOMEBODY
ADMISSION MENTIONS OF A MEDIA
INFLUENCERS- WE TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT. WHAT ARE I AD A%
MEETING TWO YEARS AGO. WITH
SOME FOLKS WHERE THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT ALL THESE.
AMAZING THINGS AS SOCIAL MEDIA
INFLUENCERS COULD DO AND THE
FACT THAT YOU DON'T REALLY WANT
THE ONES WITH. FIFTY MILLION
FOLLOWERS REALLY WANT THE ONES
WITH LIKE TEN THOUSAND
FOLLOWERS THAT THEY HAVE
REALLY- RABBIT. YOU KNOW THE
THOSE TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
FOLLOW ON EVERYWHERE THAT THEY
SAY AND EVERYTHING THEY DO
WHAT'S OUR STRATEGY ON THAT
FRONT- TO. TO TRY TO. YOU KNOW
REACH FOLKS WHERE THEY ARE. YOU
TOUCHED ON IT ACTUALLY I WOULD
SAY THAT WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
IS QUALITY OVER OVER. I IT'S
NOT ABOUT MANY. IT'S WHO IS IN
THEIR SPHERE OF INFLUENCE AND
YEAH AND THINKING STRATEGICALLY
SO WE'VE DEVELOPED A SWEET IF
YOU WELL AND DIGITAL
AMBASSADORS- BOTH AT THE
REGIONAL LEVEL ALL THE WAY UP
TO THE CELEBRITY. HERE WHEN IT
AND WHERE IT MAKES SENSE GIVEN
OUR H. T. C. TARGETED AUDIENCE-
CCD ON OUT ON A LITTLE BIT TO.
WHAT WE'RE DOING OR- PERHAPS
THAT'S AS FAR AS YOUR QUESTION
WELL IT MEANS. THAT IF YOU. I'M
THE SUCH INFLUENCE OUR CAMPAIGN
IS REALLY COMPRISED OF A COUPLE
OF THINGS- ORGANIC- MESSAGING.
WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY TALKING
TO THEIR AUDIENCES ON THEIR OWN
BUT ALSO WERE DOING A DIGITAL
COMPONENT WHERE WERE BOOSTING
THOSE MESSAGES. AND REALLY
SERVING THEM OUT INTO THE
UNIVERSE THROUGH YOU TO.
FACEBOOK INSTAGRAM OF SOCIAL-
COMPONENTS. THE IDEA BEHIND IT
IS TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO THEIR
AUDIENCES AND SHARE INFORMATION
M. IN THEIR OWN VOICES- WE DO.
HAVE A RANGE. OF I AM. I'LL BE
LIKE TO CALL IT I AM. LIKE I.
STATEWIDE JUST LIKE OUR PLAN WE
HAVE STATE RIDE AND WE HAVE
REGIONAL. WE HAVE MICRO. FEEL
LIKE A MERE THIS NUMBER ARE
SOCIAL INFLUENCE OUR CAMPAIGN.
AND SO WHAT YOU'RE GOING SEE A
ROLE OUT OVER THE NEXT. I'D SAY
NINETY DAYS OF DIFFERENT SOCIAL
INFLUENCERS WITH DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS WITH DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY AFFECT IN
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES- THAT HAVE
MESSAGES THAT ARE RELEVANT TO
THEIR AUDIENCES AND SOME THAT
ARE THAT THEIR OWN. PASSIONS I
WILL ACTUALLY BE TOMORROW IN
PRODUCTION WITH SEVERAL OF OUR-
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED I AM SOCIAL
INFLUENCERS WHERE THEY ARE
ACTUALLY GET TO PICK TOPICS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO. KNOW
LIKE DANNY TRY HOW HIS IS
HELPLESS SO HE'S REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT AND SO
WE'LL BE DOING SOME OUT THAT
HELP THEM BE UPLIFTING THROUGH
SOCIAL. I AM AROUND THAT TOPIC
GROUP. THE MEDIA PLAN IS TRY TO
IN THIS KIND OF FOLLOWING A ON
ON A- THE LAST PANEL BUT WILL A
PLAN INCLUDE A STRATEGY TO
INFORM HDZ INDIVIDUALS OF THE
LOCATIONS OF A- THE QUACKS AND
CRACKS IN YOUR THAT-
ESPECIALLY. AT ARE YES AND IN
PARTICULAR WITH THOSE WITH
LIMITED ROCK BANDS OF DEMI
BOTH. ONLINE AND OFFLINE THING
MOST OF THAT DONE THROUGHOUT MY
CAR MEDIA PLANS AND ACTUALLY
FROM THAT COUNTIES AND- THAT
THAT THAT WERE SAYING THAT ARE
DOING MEDIA WERE SAYING THAT IN
THE DIFFERENT REGIONS. WHERE
THERE'S THING THE DOLLARS TO BE
OUT SUPPORT THAT THAT IT'S A
REAL TARGETED MESSAGE COMING
FROM THAT COMMUNITY AND THAT
REGION ITSELF CONSERVE. RADIOS
ALSO. AN EXCELLENT MEDIUM IN
WHICH WE CAN- CHANGE OUT
SCRIPTS. HE JUST IN THE DIGITAL
SO I'M AS WE AS WE GET CLOSER
TO WHEN THE FACTS ARE DEPLOYED
INNOCENCE IS UNDER WAY WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
CUSTOMIZE THOSE MESSAGES IN ANY
GIVEN GEOGRAPHIC AREA. SAY
VISIT YOUR LIBRARY AND- AND YOU
KNOW WHATEVER STREET- IF WE
FEEL LIKE THAT STRATEGIES
NECESSARY TO READ. ABOUT GREAT.
I'M CENTER CABALLERO DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ONE ASK. MY
I AM I HAD AN INTERNATIONAL.
IT'S DELEGATION NO NO ASIAN AND
SO I JUST DIDN'T FEEL LIKE I
COULD I COULD TELL THEM TO WAIT
UNTIL AFTER I WAS DONE SO MY
APOLOGIES I MISSED MOST OF
EVERYTHING SO I APOLOGIZE IF
I'M AND I'M ASKING YOUR EAT IT
UP AND MY CONCERN IS THIS
CENTER ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF MY
DISTRICT IS THERE AND OF A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES. THAT
ARE- THAT ARE GOING TO BE HARD
TO- TO TRACK- NUMBER ONE IS ON
A- HOW DO YOU YEAH BUT YOU
TALKED ABOUT STATEWIDE RECALL
IN THESE MICRO REGION'S IT WITH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BE
CONSIDERED A MICRO REGION OR
WOULD IT BE- AB A REGION. SO
OUR MICRO REGIONAL. ERROR THE
STATE. SO THIS CENTRAL VALLEY
COMPRISES TWO REGIONS FOUR AND
SIX AND SO WE HAVE MEDIA LEADS
AND IN EACH OF THOSE REGIONS
JUST AS WE DO ACROSS EACH OF
THE TEN WHO ARE WORKING WITH
THE LOCAL PARTNERS ON THE
GROUND- AS WE SPEAK TO EXECUTE
A VERY CUSTOMIZED MEDIA
APPROACH IN IN YOUR REGION OKAY
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
MANY OF THE AREAS THANK YOU
YOUR BOX IS. THEIR MAIL. AND
ARE THERE LANGUAGE ISSUES AS
WELL AND THEN. OBVIOUSLY THE-
UNDOCUMENTED- ISSUE BOB WE'VE
GONE OUT AND TOLD THEM YOU
DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER THE DOOR
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND- HIMSELF. IT
SOMEBODY COMES TO YOUR HOUSE
AND NOBODY TALKED TO THEM RIGHT
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN WE GO
UPS AND THROW THAT THE WINDOW
AND WE WANT. TO TALK WE WANT
YOU TO HAVE INFORMATION- KILLER
EARLY SENSITIVE INFORMATION AT
ALL AND SO I'M I'M CA. WHAT
MEANING COMPLIANCE GOING TO BE
AND HOW WEEKEND COME ALONG SIDE
WITH WHATEVER THE COMMUNICATION
PLUS IS- TO. YOU KNOW THE BEST
COUNTING GET THIS IS THE BEST
WAY TO. STANDPOINT THAT ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN THAT WE'VE- THAT
WE'VE WORKED TO. TO DEVELOP IN
OUR CREATIVE IS ONE IS
REMINDING PEOPLE THAT THE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION IS NOT ONE
OF THE NINE QUESTIONS ON THE
CENSUS. RIGHT AND THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A TOUCH POINT FOR
THE COMMUNITY IT'S VERY THAT
HAVE BUT BECAUSE IT WAS SO.
USING THAT WAS BEING DEBATED
NATIONALLY WE WANT. A
REINFORCING THERE IS NO
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION AND JUST
BEING REALLY BLATANT ABOUT IT.
AND THEN THE SECOND I WOULD SAY
TO ADDRESS. WHAT YOU JUST. IS
TO THE THAT IF YOU DON'T FILL
OUT YOUR SINCE THIS TIME WE ARE
IS THE- CHANCE THAT ANY RATE
COME TO YOUR DOOR TO ASSIST YOU
IN AND- IN SOME COMMUNITIES
THAT. BIGGER IS EVEN GREATER
FEAR. POPS PARTICIPATING IN THE
FOR PLACE SO SEEING THAT IN
SOME OF OUR FOCUSED. WHERE
PEOPLE ARE SUGGESTING THAT IF
THEY THINK SOMEONE'S GOING TO
COME TO THEIR DOOR THERE MOLD
MORMON MOTIVATED TO RESPOND IN
THE EARLY PART OF THE SENSES
WHICH IS. WHICH IS WHAT WE WANT
TO SEE. EARLY RESPONSE THAT'S
GREAT. SO IS SO IS IT POSSIBLE
FOR US TO GET A COPY OF WHAT
YOU'RE COMMUNITY. COMMUNICATION
PLAN IS SO THAT WE CAN FIGURE
OUT HOW TO. BE MESSAGING THE
SAME KINDS OF INFORMATION- BOTH
IT. IS OF OUR OUR THE- TWO
WHERE THEY TRACK ENTERS BETTER
ALSO OURSELVES- I'M- I WANT TO.
PARTICIPATE IN. IN A COUPLE OF.
THINGS WERE I WILL BE OUT AS AT.
TRUSTED PERSON IN THE COMMUNITY
AND- BETTER I THINK IF I.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE OF
DEALING WITH THAT RIGHT UP
FRONT IT'S NOT GONNA BE ASKED
ON THE QUESTIONNAIRE AND IT
WAS. WAS PURPOSELY INTENDED DID
NOT HAVE YOU PARTICIPATE WE
NEED YOU TO PARTICIPATE KIND OF
THING SURE ABSOLUTELY NOT BUT
OF OUR AND CREATIVE AND EVEN
WITH THINGS LIKE RADIO SCRIPTS
ARE BEING SHARED BY OUR PARTNER
PORTAL YOU MIGHT REMEMBER WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
LAST TIME I THINK. WE PARTNER
PORTAL IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR WEBSITE ARE ARE ACTUALLY
FOURTEEN WEBSITES BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE- THE- SITE ITSELF IN
THIRTEEN LANGUAGES PLUS THE
PARTNER PORTAL WHAT WE'RE
HEARING A LOT ABOUT THAT. THIS
YEAR'S ONE. HE YOU'RE A POOR
FOR THE PARTNERS BE ABLE TO
ACCESS MILLION. BOB EXACT AND
ALSO SHARE. SO THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT ONLY DOWNLOADING THINGS
LIKE COLLATERAL MATERIALS AS
WELL FOR DISTRIBUTION BUT THEY
CAN UPLOAD. THEIR OWN MATERIALS
IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S
WORKING WELL IN A PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY THAT MAYBE ANOTHER
COMMUNITY COULD BENEFIT FROM.
OKAY THAT'S GOOD TO KNOW YES
THAT I HAD NOT HEARD THAT AND I
PART OF THE CHALLENGES I'VE
GOT- DE. THREE DIFFERENT WE- IN
MY DISTRICT RIGHT AND SO. YEAH
I HEARD FROM ALL OF THEM BUT
THEY PROBABLY SHOULD CHECK AND
JUST MAKE. I'M GETTING THE
RIGHT INFORMATION SIR. AND
LOOKING TO SEE. I THINK THE I
THINK THAT'S ALL I HAD FOR
RIGHT NOW. THE BILL WOULD MAKE
PEATED THE BIG PIECES THE
COMMUNICATION PLAN SO THAT WE
CAN COORDINATE OUR EFFORTS YEAH
AND I TOTALLY AGREE AND WE'RE
ALL GONNA YOU KNOW I I'M REALLY
ENCOURAGING ALL MY COLLEAGUES
AND I WAS OUT. SIDE UNITY IS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE CREATE YOUR
OWN SENSES EVENTS TO GO. TO
OTHER SENSES EVENTS THAT THAT
ARE ALREADY HAPPENING. AND SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE EQUIPPED WITH THE RIGHT
TALKING POINTS THAT ARE GONNA
RESONATE IN A POSITIVE WAY- AS
IT WAS ACCIDENTALLY SAYING
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY.
BACK AND- LOVE TO BE THE
BENEFICIARIES OF. HIS GROUPS
AND AN- INCOMING MESSAGE AS IN
THE DONE. WILL BE GREAT- SO AGO
KIND OF. TECHNICAL C<c.cyan>. I CAN</c>
YOU EXPLAIN WHAT. FIVE THIS.
ASSISTANCE FOR OUR PARTNERS SO
THAT THEY'LL KNOW WHEN THEY ARE
BEING BUILT FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. SURE I THINK THAT
WORD HAS DIFFERENT MEANINGS BUT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IT IS.
QUITE LITERALLY THE SUPPORT WE
CAN OFFER AS SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS YES. I TO SUPPORT AND
BE A PLANNED SO ACTUALLY
BUILDING THE PLAN IN EXECUTING
IT WOULD BE ONE EXAMPLE MEDIA
TRAINING. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER BE ANOTHER- AND FRANKLY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ALSO HAS A
TENDENCY. IN A GOOD WAY TO HELP
BUILD CAPACITY OF A SMALLER
ORGANIZATIONS WHO MIGHT NOT
RESOURCES FOR AND IT'S- MANY.
BASHER SO. I ONE OF THE THAT IS
THAT THAT IS. ME AT DOLLARS. I
CAN CAN BE. PUT INTO THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TECHNICIAN
BUT IT COMES IN LOTS OF
DIFFERENT FORMS GOSH. GOSH I'M
GOING TO READ SO MEDIA.
ABSOLUTELY BO SINCE FOR
INSTANCE TECHNICAL. ASSISTANCE
GOSH BUT IN TOGETHER WEAPON ARE
YOU KNOW JOINT SUPPORT TO
COMMUNICATION SUPPORT. AND
THROUGH THE SNOW SO JUST SO I
UNDERSTAND I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
REALLY GOOD QUESTION- IS. EACH
ONE OF THE REGION'S HAS A
BUDGET WITH YOU AND THEN- THE
KINDS OF THINGS THEY'D BE BILL
FOR IS THE TRAINING SO THAT THE
STAFF. MORE SAT AND HOW THE HOW
DO YOU UTILIZE THE MEDIA YEAH
COULD BE OKAY BEING AS A WHOLE
THAT SO MAYBE. OR POTENTIAL.
PERSON SO THAT HOW TO MAYBE. AT
A DEAL WITH MY AT WITH THEIR OF
FROM REALLY TALK POINTS OUT
MASS DEVELOPMENT ALL ALL OF
THOSE FOR INTO THE TECH
ASSISTANCE AND I HE LIKE IN OUR
IN RE SEVEN SOMETHING WHEN
EMPIRE YOU KNOW THERE WOULD THE
ATV- WAS WORKING WITH LIKE
EIGHTY PLUS BBO MOST HAVE
MEDICATION. WORRY BUT I HOPE.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HELP THOSE
THOSE OF A ISSUES THAT THEY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORK THE P. R.
MEDIA RELATIONS SO ARE HAVE YOU
CREATED LIKE GOOD. FOR LACK OF
A BETTER WORD A DASHBOARD OF
THE KINDS OF CONTINUE YEAH THAT
THEY THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS YOU
ASKED A- SEND OUT I'M I'M I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
THEY MAKE THE DECISION USE OF
THEIR BUDGET IF THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU COULD PROVIDE AND THEN
IT MAY BE THAT SENDING DOWN TO
ALL THE EIGHTY. FORGET. THE
MANY WOULD ALSO DO THE WORKS IN
PRAGUE IS WHERE WE ARE TALKED
DIRECT TO THE CBO SAID OUR IN
THE REGION AND IF YOU WANT TO
YEAH I'M THAT THAT IS THE ACT
THE WAY FOUND AS BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S MAY STUFF AS WERE
HAVING CALLED WERE WORKSHOPS
PAYING THEIR SHARE OF THINGS
THEY LIKE OR DON'T LIKE THINGS
THEY WANT WE'RE TALKING ON THE
PHONE OUT IDEA. RIGHT IT YES
SHARING THEM WHERE WE ANALYSIS
ON THE STATE AND THE US CENSUS
BUREAU CAMPAIGNS TO SEE WHERE
MAYBE WERE MISSING FOR SPECIFIC
THING I READ. I'M THEN I. BACK
TO THEM SOME OF THEM ARE COMING.
ALL OF THEM ARE COMING WITH THE
WAY LIST. THINGS AND THEN WE
LIKE JUST. CALL COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION ON HOW HOW TO PROCEED
NEXT EVERY REGION IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT SOME OF THE REGIONS
ARE VERY SOPHISTICATED AND
SUMMER LIKE WE DON'T HAVE TIME
CAN YOU. BE MORE HANDS ON SO
WE'RE TRYING TO BE RESPONSIVE
TO THEIR NEEDS AND IN SOME
CASES WERE PROBABLY NOT MOVING
AS FAST AS WE CAN BECAUSE WERE.
TRYING TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY'S
OUT A LEVELS AT THAT EVERYBODY
HAS THE SAME INFORMATION- AND
IN OTHER WAYS. PROBABLY MOVE
THE REGION'S WE MAY BE MOVING
STAR THAN- THAN OTHERS. I'M IT
ROOM AND- THE AN APP XIN AND WE
ARE CLOSE HAVING THE MICRO
MEDIA PLANS FINALIZED ARE. WE
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE ALL THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT DOLLARS
ASSIGNED WE JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS THEY MAY
NOT KNOW WHAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED. SO WE'RE
PLANNING THE MEDIAN DOLLARS AND
WE'RE KEEPING 10% RECOMMENDING
10% BE SET ASIDE FOR. NORFOLK
SUMMER CHOOSING TO DO MORE-
BECAUSE I REALLY FEEL LIKE THEY
MIGHT NEED IT THERE. AND SO
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO BE- CUT
SOME TO THE REGION. IN CYNICAL
WHERE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
EARLIER NORTH THROUGH. AN ACT.
NON RESPONSE FOR UP. YEAH THANK
YOU. JUNE AND JULY. SORRY SO IF
I COULD MAKE THIS A BECAUSE
YOUR APPS RIGHT I WHEN I WAS
GETTING TO IS THAT SOME AREAS
ARE MORE SOPHISTICATED AND
OTHERS AND SOME- SOME OF THE
COMMUNITY GROUPS THE REASON
THAT THEY BEEN CHOSEN IS
BECAUSE THEY AREN'T THIS UNIT
IN THERE GOING OUT IN THERE
TALKING PEERS AND WE YOU EL
MANY HARD ACCOUNT. INDIVIDUALS
ON. AND I NEED SOMEONE TO SPEAK
THEIR IN THAT LOOK LIKE THEM
THAT WILL FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH ALL OF THAT AND SO- AT MY
SUGGESTION I'M BECAUSE- I KNOW
YOU'LL FIND THIS HARD TO
BELIEVE BUT WE ALL ARE YOU
INTERESTED REGION'S WE- IS
THAT- IS KIND OF A- HAD A
REPORT CARD BUT JUST SOMETHING
THAT TELLS YOU BY REGION HERE.
WHAT THE BASS WERE HERE'S WHAT
WE'VE DONE AND IN IT IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE FANCY JUST HAS TO
BE. AT LEAST A SOME
INFORMATION- IS SO THAT IF
SOMEONE ASKS YOU KNOW IN MY
DISTRICT WHAT KIND OF TRAINING
HAVE YOU DONE YOU'VE GOT A LIST
FOR YOU CAN LOOK AT IT VERY
QUICKLY SAY WE DID THIS THIS
AND THIS AND IF. I DO. THEY IT
OVER. AND GIVEN HOW MANY
DISTRICTS ARE ARE CALIFORNIA'S
REALLY COMPLICATED YES AND
EVERY REGION IS REALLY
DIFFERENT- SO IT IS THAT THE
KINDS OF THINGS IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S EVERYBODY GOT EQUAL IT
JUST REALLY IS IN A WORK- BUT
BUT IF THERE HAVE BEEN THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND THERE'S A
WAIT THE TO DOCUMENT HERE'S
WHAT DONE IN IN THESE BINS I IT
MIGHT HELP TO ALLOW SOME OF THE
TURN THE PEOPLE BECAUSE- I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT. ALL I HAVE
SEEN LOT ABOUT THE CENSUS BUT I
MAY I MAY JUST HAVE MISSED WHEN
THEY COME ON- WHERE WHERE
THEY'RE BEING SHOWN AND SO- I
GET PARANOID ABOUT IT AND I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT. THAT WE
GET AN ACCURATE COUNT. SO
ANYWAY I CAN BE HELPFUL I WANT
TO DO THAT JUST SO LEAVING A
YOUR CONCERNS I AM WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT BEFORE YOU CAME AND
THEN. IT IS GOING TO BE A PART
TO ANTHONY I. I'M JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE. SORRY THAT'S A GOOD
THING YEAH THINK THAT BUT WE
DID SAY WE WOULD PROVIDE KIND
OF LIKE AN UPDATE SO I KINDA
LET YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS GOING
ON SO YOU GUYS AREN'T LIKE IS
IT HAPPENING YOU KNOW AND
PROBABLY A REALLY GOOD NOT THAT
THAT WAS FINE I HAD JUST INTO
OF HAVING IDENTIFYING HERE'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN IN THE
DISTRICTS AND HERE'S THE
DIFFERENT. THE FRIEND.
ORGANIZATION BUT ACTUALLY IT'S
A DIFFERENT. I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE. MINORITY
GROUPS AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THERE ARE. ALL PROBABLY
ALL EIGHTEEN ARE LOCATED THERE
MOSTLY BECAUSE THERE THERE THEY
COME AND LOOK FOR A JOB THAT
THEY'RE FAMILIAR WITH AT HOME
SO THEY END UP IN AGRICULTURE-
SO THAT THE MORE THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING WE CAN LOOK AT AND
FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT IT'S
GETTING OUT THERE WELL I'LL BE
OUT THERE TOO BUT I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENT. WE MA NOT SEE.
YOU'RE PROBABLY RIGHT. SOME OF
THE COMPLY WELL WHEN YOU'RE
DRIVING AROUND YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO SEE BILL FOR THAT THEN I
WILL TELL YOU. THAT'LL MAKE ME
FEEL BETTER. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE IT YEAH SO WE'RE
GONNA SWITCHED- TO PUBLIC
COMMENT- NOW WHAT DOES HAVE ONE
MINUTE PER COMMENTER AND PLEASE
MAKE SURE TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF
IF YOU'RE WITH AN ORGANIZATION
THANKS OFF. HI GOOD AFTERNOON A
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CENTER CERAM
SANTANA I'M WITH- CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. AND WE ARE
A COMMUNITY BASED CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
CHINATOWN. AND SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE WE'VE WORKED ON EVERY
DECENNIAL CENSUS FOR THE PAST
FIVE DECADES. FIRST WE WANT TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE AND ITS
STAFF FOR THE COMMITTEE IT'S
SHOWN UP FOR LANGUAGE ACCESS
THAT MISTREATED IN EVERY LAST
YEAR SO THANK YOU. I'M GIVEN
THE EXPERIENCE HAPPENED WHAT
LYNN WAS PROFICIENT COMMUNITIES
MODEL COMMUNITIES UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES FOR THE PAST FIFTY
YEARS- THERE ARE WE DOWN TO YOU
KNOW. WE KNOW THERE'S ABOUT A
NINETY DAYS UNTIL APRIL FIRST.
AND TO GIVEN THE EXISTING
EFFORTS THAT ARE STILL BEING
CONDUCTED BY STATE CENSUS AT
THE MERCURY- THERE ARE THREE
KEY THINGS THAT I THINK WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT THE BENEFIT FROM.
SO WHAT. LANGUAGE PLAN AND
MEDIA REACHED THESE THREE
THINGS SHOULD BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. ONE THEY SHOULD
TRACK. THE DOLLAR. THE LANGUAGE
GROUP. IMPORTANT IT'S- A-
WHAT'S RESOURCE. ARE GOING TO
BE TO PLAY. FOR WHICH SPUR.
ELLIE P. GROUP. AND NOT ONLY
TRACK IT BUT HOW MUCH MONEY IS
BEING SPENT ON WHICH LANGUAGE
GROUP. IN WHAT RATE OF THE TEN
REGION'S. TO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO PRIORITIZE THE
MEDIA CONTRACTS FOR NON ENGLISH
LANGUAGES THEIR LATEST REPORT
THAT CAME OUT JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH STATES THAT THE MEDIA
COMPLETE THE ETHNIC MEDIA
COMPONENT. IS CORE TO THERE ARE
PAID MEDIA PLAN AND IF IT IS
COR WE BELIEVE AT LEAST 75% OF
THE DOLLARS FOR. CONTRACTS BE
MARKED AS MEET. ALSO FOR A
HOLDERS KNOW WHAT LANGUAGE
THOSE ME BUYS WILL BE MADE.
WHAT LANGUAGES WILL LEFT BE
LEFT OUT WHY ARE THEY LEFT OUT
AND WHO ARE GOING TO FILL THOSE
GAPS AT THAT POINT REAL QUICKLY
THIRD POINT REALLY QUICKLY WITH.
YOUR TIES THE MINORITY THE
LINGUISTICALLY SMALL GROUPS FOR
MEDIA OUTREACH I KEEP HEARING
ABOUT THE THIRTEEN LANGUAGES
THEY'RE GONNA BE DEPLOYED THE
MEAT AND YOU KNOW THE MARKETING
IN THE THIRTEEN. WHAT HAPPENS
TO THOSE OF THE KEY LANGUAGES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT AREN'T
SUPPORTED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI JULIAN IRWIN POLICY FELLOW
FOR ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA- JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT WALL SOME IN
LANGUAGE CENSUS MATERIALS ARE
BEING DEVELOPED A TRANSLATED
FOR OUT REACH POINT PURPOSES.
THERE HASN'T BEEN MUCH
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THESE MATERIALS
IN PHYSICAL FORM. SO THERE HAVE
BEEN GREAT EFFORTS TO
INCORPORATE NON MANDATORY
LANGUAGES AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE STATE PRO ACTIVELY
PUSHING REGIONAL A CBO'S TO
SHARE OUR RESOURCES AND SEE
GRANT OR STIPE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO REACH THE SMALL GROUPS TO
THE EXTENT THE STATE IS RELYING
ON STATEWIDE HE DOES LIKE A
DANCING IS UP I AND CARE. THESE
LANGUAGE NEED. IT'S CHALLENGING
FUNDING FOR HOLD OFFICE. I
THINK MEDIA IS THE CORE THE PAY
MEDIA STAR. AS SUCH WE ADVOCATE
THAT 75% OF FUNDS DESIGNATED
FOR MEDIA CONTRACT SHOULD BE
EARMARKED FOR NON ENGLISH
LANGUAGES. WE SHOULD KNOW WHICH
LANGUAGES THERE WILL BE MEDIA
PURCHASES IN AND HOW MUCH IS
BEING SPENT ON THAT WHAT
LANGUAGES ARE BEING LEFT OUT OF
THE MEDIA PURCHASES AND WHY.
FINALLY THERE SHOULD BE A
FORMAL PLAN FOR MEDIA OUT REACH
TO THE SMALLER LINGUISTIC
LANGUAGE GROUPS THAT ARE NOT
PART OF THE STATE'S MANDATORY
LANGUAGES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON CO
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS ANDREA
RIVERA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER I'M HERE TODAY TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE- BY CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE-
FIRST TO PRIORITIZE- MEDIA
OUTRAGE FOR LINGUISTIC
LINGUISTIC MINORITY GROUPS
SECOND TO PRIORITIZE OUT REACH
OR MEDIA CONTRACTS FOR NON
ENGLISH LANGUAGE GROUPS. AND
FINALLY ENSURING THAT WE TRACK
THE DOLLARS THAT ARE SPENT ON
OR WILL BE SPENT ON- OUT REACH
PLANS- FOR THESE HARD TO REACH
GROUPS- AGAIN ENSURING THAT ALL
THESE THINGS ARE INCLUDED IN
THE FINAL LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
MEDIA COMMUNICATIONS PLANS WILL
ENSURE THAT WE CAN COLLECT
INFORMATION THAT IS TRULY
REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE POPULATION. THANK YOU.
MY ANGER M. A FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA WANT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS OF THE COLLEAGUES THAT
SPOKE BEFORE ME EMPHASIZE THE
NEED TO TRACK OF WHAT IS SPENT
IN LANGUAGE GROUPS BY REGION.
TO ALSO ENSURE THAT THE GRANTS
GO OUT TO- NON ENGLISH
LANGUAGES THAT WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT LANGUAGE WE'RE SORT FUNDED
OUT LEVEL AND WHAT LANGUAGES
WERE LEFT OUT AND WHY. AND WORK
HARD TO REACH LINGUISTIC
MINORITY GROUPS OTHER THAN THE
TWELFTH THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE STATE PLAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU JUDY ROBINSON TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS MANAGER FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY- SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF- SACRAMENTO COUNTY
COMPLETE COUNTS. SO A SENATOR
PAN WOULD LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO
JOIN US APRIL FIST CANVASSING.
THAT'S GOING TO BE ONE OF OUR
ACTIVITIES GOING ON- ALSO
WORKING FOR A FREE RIGHTS ALL
DAY ON RT SO AND ANYWAY- BUT MY
COMMENTS TO THE POINT. IS
HERE'S SOME OF THE LOCAL
BRANDING THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR SACRAMENTO- AND THEN ALSO
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS PART OF
REGION ONE. OF LOOKING FOR TO
COPE ENDING WITH THIS EIGHT BE
ABLE TO MISS THE- UP. THE I'M
OF THE CO BRANDED GOING ON. THE
QUESTION I'D LIKE TO ASK ON IS
FOR THE STATE TO CA THAT THIS
ALL GRAY BUT IF CAN'T FIND THE
WEBSITE OR IF THEY'RE GOING TO
THE WRONG WEBSITE- BUT THAT
THAT THAT THERE IS A STATE
COORDINATED EFFORT WITH ALL OF
THE PARTNERS ALL OF THE
WEBSITES THAT WE SET UP THAT ON
MARCH TWELFTH OUR WEBSITES TO
LIVE WITH MY TWENTY TWENTY
CENTS DOT GOT AN AND HERE'S THE
WEBSITE WHERE YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONNAIRE HERE ARE PHONE
NUMBERS TO CALL. SO THAT
EVERYONE GETS DIRECTED TO THE
SAME INFORMATION SO THAT-THEY'RE THEY'RE ON THE RIGHT ON
POINT SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU AND WHEN DO I
GET A COPY THAT. WELL RIGHT NOW
BUT YOU. WELCOME HI A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON- BERMAN
AND SHOPPERS IN PANAMA VERSE OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON CENSUS
MY NAME IS NANCY JOHN AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNICATIONS FOR MOM INVOLVED
EIGHT INNOVATING POLITICS FOR
HIP ARE WE ARE CURRENTLY THE
LEAD FOR THE API SINCE BECAUSE
SUBCOMMITTEE BACKGROUND COUNTY
AND IMPLEMENTING SENSES OUR
REGION EDUCATION IN HARD TO
COUNT AB. ACTS FOR COUNTY TO
FRESNO I WON TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING THIS
CRITICAL CONVERSATION AND FOR
RECOGNIZING THE CRITICAL NEED
FOR CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
COMMUNICATION TACTICS. YOUR
INVESTMENTS INCENTIVES ARE
WHICH IS UNPRECEDENTED AND WE
SHARE IN YOUR DESIRE TO ENSURE
THESE. DOLLARS WHICH THE
HARDEST TO CAMP POPULATIONS IN
THE STATE. MUCH OF TODAY'S
DISCUSSION HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
TRANSPARENCY AND THAT'S VERY
HERE SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WOULD BE LEFT BELIEVE WILL
HELP IN THAT PROCESS. SO FIRST
IT WILL BE HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE DOLLARS
BEING SPENT ON THE AFTER MEDIA
ARE BEING ALLOCATED
SPECIFICALLY WHAT MARKETS
LANGUAGES IN POPULATIONS ARE.
THE PRIMARY FOCUS OF THESE
DOLLARS THIS WILL HELP
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE LEGISLATOR
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE GAPS AND
ALSO THE OPPORTUNITIES WE
LEVERAGE TO SHIP ARE
MOBILIZING. WHAT LIES ATION
EFFORTS TOWARDS. SECOND WE ARE
EAGER TO PARTNER WITH MERCURY
IN THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE OF MESSAGING WE USE IS
INCLUSIVE AND CONNECTS TO THE
LOCAL MOBILIZATION BROWN. WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE GENERAL
EDUCATION- COMMUNICATION
EFFORTS WILL NOT CONNECT WITH
AVAILABLE SERVICES- BEING
DEPLOYED ON THE GROUND. WE CAN
GUARD AGAINST THIS TO
DISCONNECT BY HAVING AN ONGOING
ENGAGEMENT OF WITH STAKEHOLDERS
RATHER THAN SIMPLY LEAVE A
VETTING- FINISH CONTACT AT THE
VERY END OF PRODUCTION. THANK
YOU. THANK EVERYBODY SO MUCH
I'M GONNA RUSH OUT- BUT THAT'S
ALSO THE END OF THE HEARING AL
ALL IT DOCTOR BEING CLOSED- BUT
JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE- AND FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU GOING TO DO. OVER THE NEXT
FORTY NINE DAYS I THINK UNTIL
APRIL FIRST- AND THEN FOR THE
THREE MONTHS AFTER THAT- YEAH
THERE WAS A FOUR MONTHS FOUR
MONTHS I THINK AFTER THAT-
BEFORE JETTING MORE. THANKS
THANKS VERY MUCH AT YOUR BERMAN
I JUST ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL
MY COLLEAGUES WHO- WHO. WHO
CAME TO THIS HEARING AND- ASK
QUESTIONS- SAID WE ARE- A MONTH
AWAY. FROM THE- PEOPLE GETTING
NOTICES A MONTH AND A HALF AWAY
FROM THE LAUNCH. AND THEN- WE
BASICALLY- HAVE. YOU KNOW ONE
SHOT. WROTE EIGHT OF. THIS SO.
I THINK. WE WANT TO HAVE THIS
HEARING TO BE SURE. IF WE IF
THERE'S ANY LAST ADJUSTMENTS
ARE. THIS IS THE TIME AS I SAID
BEFORE- FOR US TO SHARE
INFORMATION SO THAT WE'RE ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE AS WE LUNCH
RIGHT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE. BACK TO LESTER KNOCKED
DOWN SAID. WELL I'M TALKING THE
MERCURY. IN THIS OFFICE DARK TO
AN ACE. YOU KNOW I. HOW TO
SUPPORT AN AUGMENTED WELL
OBVIOUSLY BEING YOU KNOW PART
OF STATE GOVERNMENT SO- SO
THAT- BUT- BY WORKING TOGETHER
AND- SHARING THINGS WITH EACH
OTHER WORKING TOGETHER BEING
SURE THAT WE KNOW WHAT EACH
OTHER PERSON IS DOING WE CAN.
ALL INDIVIDUALLY BOTH YOU KNOW
OPTIMIZE WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
TRY TO BE SURE WE HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL CENSUS. AND SO I'VE
AT ADMIT THAT I. ACTUALLY EVEN
THOUGH SOME OF US HAD SOME
PRETTY TOUGH QUESTIONS AND WHY
THEY HAVE MORE INFORMATION. I'M
GOOD EXPRESS MY CONFIDENCE
THAT. SENTENCE IS GONNA GO VERY
WELL HERE CALIFORNIA WE'VE MADE
MORE AT LARGER INVESTMENT I
THINK. IT'S MEANT BEING SPENT
APPROPRIATELY I MEAN WE CAN
BEGIN TO. FOR TO A SUCCESSFUL
SO. I AM LOOKING FOR TO US
COUNTING. BETTER IN ANY OTHER
STATE WE WILL BE NUMBER ONE
AGAIN CALIFORNIA AND BE SURE WE
COUNT AS MANY L. GET HIRED
CLOSER TO ANY OTHER STATE TO
COUNTY EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO
LIVES IN THIS STATE SO. I
APPRECIATE THAT OPPORTUNITY
ONCE A- NUMBER OKAY ALL RIGHT
WELL THEN WHAT THAT I WANT
THANK EVERYONE ALL THE PRESENT
WHO ARE SHE- WE HAVE A LOT WORK
AHEAD OF US. LOOKING FOR TO
SUCCESSFUL CENSUS SO WITH THAT
THIS YEAR AS THE JOINT SELECT
COMMITTEES ON THE CENSUS OF
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU.